This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com.
That's o n n I t a human optimization
website.
We Sell Shit that makes your body work
better,
whether it's nutritious supplements
like,
or snacks like the warrior bar,
one of our new products made by the same
company that makes the Tonka Bar,
which,
uh,
is a,
a buffalo bar,
like a buffalo jerky bar with natural
cranberries and natural native American
recipe.
No antibiotics,
no added hormones,
gluten free,
and no nitrates either.
It's an ancient way of making this sort
of meat bar.
There are only 140 calories,
four grams of fat,
and 14 grams of protein.
Super healthy for you.
No MSG,
no soy,
no lactose,
gluten free,
no nitrates,
no antibiotics.
I mean,
you can't get any better as far as like
healthy high protein snacks and they're
fucking delicious.
It is the real original native American
ref recipe of doing it with cranberries.
Try it.
It's yummy snack.
Um,
we just try to sell whatever we find
that,
uh,
is,
is available for sale that,
uh,
makes you feel better.
It's things that make your body work
better,
whether it's trunk functional strength
that you can acquire from strength and
conditioning equipment like kettlebells
or battle ropes or a weight vest or ab
wheels.
We just try to sell the things that we
use and it on it.com.
Whether it is supplements like Alpha
brain or whether it's a hemp protein
powder.
All the things we sell are things that I
use,
Aubrey,
my partner uses and things that we find
that are interesting.
Um,
all of the supplements have science
behind them.
There's all a sheet with references,
uh,
showing you why the ingredients were
chosen and what the benefits of those
ingredients are.
And we also have a 90 day 30 pill,
100 percent money back guarantee on any
of the supplements you buy from on it.
If you don't like the way it works or
you don't think it's worth it,
you don't even have to return the
bottle.
You just get your money back.
That's just because we're trying to sell
you the best shit.
We can sell you all things that we use
and do it in a very ethical way.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t use
the Codeword Rogan and you will save 10
percent off any and all supplements
world.
Also brought to you by.
Well this episode is brought to you buy
naturebox.
Naturebox is my newest addiction around
the office and a lot of people on my
message board.
I had questions about exactly how
healthy it is.
Well,
you can vary it at naturebox.
You could be like a real freak and go,
uh,
the gluten free route,
which is how I did it.
Or you can get a little sketchy with
shit like pretzels.
Let's be honest.
It's only you can only make pretzels so
healthy.
There's really not a lot you could do to
them that makes them actually healthy.
Pretzels are fucking pretzels man.
But what naturebox do have products are
natural and contained a much higher
quality ingredients than the typical
vending machine.
Food ingredients there is over 100
snacks.
Choose from.
And if you look for something with
certain dietary needs,
like wheat free,
lower sugar content,
etc. They have that too.
And whenever possible They try to use
non gmo food as well.
Their products are made from wholesome
ingredients.
And nutritionist approve the abide by
very strict quality standards,
no high fructose corn syrup,
no pipe,
partially hydrogenated oils,
no trans fats,
no artificial sweeteners,
no artificial colors,
no artificial flavors.
So it's wAy healthier than most bullshit
that you're getting from vending
machines.
That's the idea behind it.
And again you can get it is variable is
like fairly healthy pretzels or what my
favorite really healthy is these things
are delicious,
man.
I got these sweet blueberry almonds.
Oh they're so ridiculous.
They're so good.
I ate them all up.
I need more in these plantations are
fucking delicious too.
And these are pretty guilt free,
you know,
south pacific plantings.
Naturebox.com.
Really very cool company.
I enjoy them.
They're snacks.
So go there and check that shit out.
And we're also brought to you.
Well I got to give you a quote.
Go to naturebox.com/rogan.
That's naturebox.com/rogan.
Go there and you will get 50 percent off
your first box.
So naturebox.com/rogan.
I'm telling you,
try these sweet blueberry almonds.
They're fucking ridiculously good and
guilt free.
They free,
uh,
the ship for free.
Also anywhere in the us.
Naturebox is busting up the vending
machines monopoly on your midday hunger.
Naturebox.com/rogan were also brought to
you by legalzoom and this is the last
one,
I swear.
Legal zoom is a way to do all sorts of
legal things online from the comfort of
your home.
Instead of actually having to go to a
lawyer's office and schedule an
appointment,
it's also accompanied that we have used
brian red bands,
used it.
Arbor used to secure on it and make it
an llc.
Super easy To do things like that
online.
They guide you through it.
They also have third party independent
attorneys that can connect you to,
if you ever get into a panic and think
that you're going to jail because what
you're doing is totally illegal.
They can let you know.
Legal zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third
party attorney and provide you with self
help.
Services and the self help services are
very easy to follow.
In the past 12 years,
over 2 million americans have used legal
zoom and they've saved a ton of money.
Things like start your own business,
incorporate form an llc for starting at
99 bucks.
You can protect your family with a last
will for just $69 bucks or get a living
trust.
Power of attorney and legal zoom is
recommended by nine out of 10 customers
that have used it,
which is an incredible number.
When you think about how many douche
bags there are there in the world.
One out of 10 for sure,
when I attend people's a fucking idiot.
so if nine out of 10 say legal zoom is
worth doing,
again,
I would say it's a very good company.
They Also have an a plus from the better
business bureau and that's very
important.
So just think of that legalzoom.com.
Use the code word rogan at checkout.
I'll use the word rogan in the referral
box at checkout for more savings.
That's legalzoom.com.
it is an awesome,
awesome surface.
Okay,
ladies and gentlemen,
peter giuliano.
Hey,
am I saying it correctly?
perfect.
Is here.
We're going to talk about some coffee.
We're going to get some knowledge.
You can play the music,
the job
login experience,
joe rogan podcast by night all day.
I love when people are really,
really,
really into shit and user are really,
really into coffee.
That's true.
And what's important about people like
you is that people like me who really do
love coffee,
but I know nothing about it and I'm not
going to do all that research.
It's just not going to happen,
man.
It's just too,
too much work.
I need someone like you out there that's
obsessed with coffee that can bring me
some coffee that smells like lemons.
I'm here for you.
What is this stuff that you brought?
You brought this ethiopian blend that
was warm when we got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
um,
I brought you ethiopian coffee because
okay.
At some point.
So I'm a coffee guy,
right?
I've been working in coffee for years,
25 years or more.
And when you're a coffee guy,
everybody asks you their coffee
questions.
And the number one question that people
start asking you is,
what's your favorite coffee?
You know,
everybody wants to know that.
So now most coffee people,
when they're asked that question a
little bit,
the way I lied was I would say a that's
like asking a parent who their favorite
child is.
You know what I mean?
You can't,
you're not allowed
to.
You got a coffee problem.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
I got allowed to do that.
Right.
You're not allowed to do that.
You're not allowed to play favorites,
et cetera.
But,
uh,
putting that lie aside,
most coffee people are affectionate
about coffee from Ethiopia because
that's where coffees from originates.
It originates.
Of course.
I'm going to be beautiful shit out.
It smells so good.
By the way,
what is the name of this particular
blend that you made?
It's
called yirgacheffe.
And you're a chef is the name of a town
in southern Ethiopia and it is in coffee
to coffee people.
You're a chef.
Is like a mecca.
Yeah,
that's the spot.
This smells unbelievable.
That's what.
And that's why it it.
It's uh,
it's so famous.
The coffee smells like flowers and um,
and then like lemons,
like lemon oil or something.
And that's really unique if you,
if you taste coffee that tastes,
smells and case like this,
it's almost certain that it comes from
Ethiopia because because of the variety
they grow there because the way that
they process it,
etc. It makes it really special.
So,
um,
this was roasted by,
by company in san francisco called
wrecking ball coffee and the coffee is
called Ethiopia classic yirgacheffe
classic meaning shove again.
Why I g m,
why I g
r wait,
sorry.
Y I r g a,
c h e f,
f e isn't a weird thing where you have
to write it down to look at it to make
sure it's right.
Well,
the other weird thing too is that that's
one way to spell it.
There's like if you're in yoga chef and
you look at signs,
they're all spelled a different way
because it's actually an mri tech.
It's a different language and they just
translate it to english and various
ways.
So you can spell it.
There's,
I've been in involved in internet.
Okay.
Here's another coffee geek admission.
I've been involved in these internet
conversations about how you should spell
yoga show also how you should pronounce
it,
but in in ethiopian they pronounce it
differently in a way that I can't
actually pronounce it.
How do they say give it a shot or a gut
check or good chef.
Yeah,
exactly.
The last thing is like,
it's like a breathing,
but you just did it when,
how we get to do it.
There was an ethiopian guy next to me.
Yeah,
exactly.
I feel like,
you know,
like saying I've just been to roma or
something like that is a weird thing.
Have my friend amber lyon who's coming
on the podcast soon.
She was talking about boxing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Instead of Bahrain,
which is almost,
she was saying,
but then she,
she let it go and she said,
by rain,
I'm like,
wait a minute.
I got to be one or the other here in
southern California in the newscasters
suddenly just goes into the perfect
spanish pronunciation.
Yes,
yes.
Burrito.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's very important.
If you want to maintain the latin
audience,
you gotta roll your r's.
But anyway,
I don't try for that with coffee names
because it's a little too low.
Well,
you're taking a chance on being like
already like kind of labeled as a crazy
coffee person.
But if you could pronounce all the words
then the pretentiousness level.
It gets very risky.
Well,
it's,
you know,
that's the thing with being a coffee
person,
you know,
because people are afraid that you're
going to be like a kind of a douchebag
about,
about your coffee,
you know,
because.
Because it's a weird conundrum because
on the one hand people like that you
take it seriously and,
and because you're trying to,
you're trying to make,
you know,
embrace something that's super delicious
and you want it to be more delicious and
better tasting and stuff like that.
And so that causes you to learn stuff
about the geography of where coffee
comes from and all this weird trivia,
you know,
and,
uh,
you start to learn about that stuff and
it's good.
But at the Same time,
it's very easy when you get really into
something to start to alienate people,
you know,
and that goes for anything that goes for
wine or food or you know,
any sort of hobby,
you know,
when people can't talk about anything
else and then they start to get kind of
snobby about stuff.
But.
And so it's a struggle for coffee people
all the time,
you know,
because what I know and I've learned in
my many years of doing this thing is
that,
especially in the morning,
you know,
people just want their coffee,
they don't want to fuck around with,
with,
you know all this,
stuff like that.
And we learned that in,
in,
you know.
So I started as a barista.
I worked for many,
many years as a barista behind the car,
behind the bar,
making people their coffee in the
morning.
so do you really appreciate like when
someone's a connoisseur,
like the difference between the guys,
like I just want a cup of coffee and a
guy's like,
what's your blends today?
A guy like who's really into it?
Lots of times it's the same person,
like a person that later in the day will
be like all into what kind of coffee it
is and really particular everybody just
their first cup of coffee,
they just want a freaking cup of coffee.
Even even coffee pros like me,
you know,
we dispense with all that stuff that,
that time when you know you've been
there,
you wake up in the morning,
you don't know what's going on.
All you want is a cup of coffee and
people to be nice to you for the first
couple of hours of your day.
Usually most of the time when I don't
have any time and I just want some sort
of caffeine,
I,
I have one of those little suppress
things.
Will you put those little capsules in
there and you catch it down,
you press the button and a shot of
espresso comes out.
Um,
are those bad?
Well,
it doesn't taste as good as the real.
That's the thing.
They're convenient,
you know,
and,
and whether they're there,
there's a lot of disadvantages to a,
to a thing like that.
On the other hand,
I've tasted delicious coffee out of,
out of those real.
If the coffee going in is,
is good if the machine is working right?
I mean there's all sorts of different
kinds of machines.
WhaT is the expect you to know this
because you don't manufacture these
things,
but what is the.
Is there plastic right?
Is that what it is?
Like a,
some out of aluminum.
Others that are made out of plastic?
Yeah.
I think the ones I have are aluminum.
So is that stuff okay for the flavor
when you're heating that up,
eating up the illumina.
It doesn't mess it up.
Yeah.
That's not the problem.
The problem that's aluminum is pretty
resistant to stuff like that.
And they make that metal work,
you know,
it's like a soda pop cans so they have
an engineered it to work well.
So it's not an issue with flavor,
it's just an issue of what's in it will
rise and also how the,
how the machine works.
So if like you guys made coffee here
today and you did it in a great way by
boiling the water in a kettle and then
you have a french press and use it.
now,
the great thing about that is that
you're boiling the water.
The water is getting to 212.
That's where it boils.
And then by the time you pour it in the
french press,
it's cooled off.
Maybe it's 200,
seven,
205.
Is that where you should have it at 195
to 205 degrees is where you should be.
Oh my gosh.
It's crazy.
I know he,
he got so intense,
195 to 200,
five degrees and sunny spot.
It is,
it's the honey spot.
That's what,
that's where we get guys like me get
fired up over stuff like,
well we bought today's the first day of
using it here.
What I have at home,
which is I think it's called breville b
r e v I l l e and it's uh,
it'll show you like you could have one
button for oolong tea.
the other button for french press and so
this was the french press button.
So I assume they get it right then.
That's even better than what it did.
And this is breville.
They make some wonderful,
incredible coffee equipment.
Yeah,
they do.
And uh,
and so the french press button will,
I'm sure get it to 205 degrees.
We should put a thermometer in that
bitch.
Find out whether or not I bet.
Find out we need a thermometer.
Just me.
And it's very important.
Um,
well that's the thing guys like me,
we have thermometers at home because we,
it makes a difference.
So.
No,
but check this out.
So I believe what I was going to say is
the machines,
whether it's a pod machine or a capsule
machine like you're talking about or a
mr coffee type machine,
black and decker,
whatever,
all those kinds of coffee machines.
One of the big challenges with those
things as if they don't get hot enough.
If they're brewing coffee at 180
degrees,
it's going to taste like crap.
And so you're cooking it while you're
brewing it.
Yeah,
exactly.
So the water is hot,
you know,
some amount of hot and if it's,
and if it's the right amount of hot in
between one and 95 and 205,
right about 200 degrees,
then it makes the coffee taste.
So it actually literally changes the
flavor that's coming out of the beans
when it's hot enough to activate it,
right?
So,
and too hot is bad,
too hot is bad.
And so here's,
here's the deal with coffee.
It's like if you looked at it under a
microscope,
took a slice of it and then looked at
that under a microscope,
you'd see all the cellular structure of
the coffee and it's like a sponge.
And inside the sponge is all the oils
and sugars and fats and stuff that may
really complicated.
It's thousands of little different
chemicals in there that,
um,
that you need to get out of the sponge.
You need to essentially rinse it out of
the coffee to get it into your cup.
And that's what brewing is all about.
Now,
um,
if you don't do that well enough,
you leave all the good tasting stuff in
the coffee that sponge,
the coffee cell walls,
you know,
and it doesn't get into your cup and
your,
and your coffee doesn't taste very good
and plus you've wasted all the good
stuff.
You wind up throwing it in the trash.
If the opposite thing happens,
if you extract too much out of the
coffee,
if you squeeze that sponge till it's
perfectly dry,
then the last stuff to get extracted
tastes kind of bitter.
And uh,
like tannic,
it,
it doesn't,
it doesn't taste good.
It has a characteristic that we call
over extracted.
And so that bitter tannin comes from a
prolonged exposure to hot water.
Either the water being too hot
or you bring it for too long or a.
Or like for example,
if you boiled coffee like they used to
do in the cowboy days,
he used to like boil coffee over the
campfire that will make the coffee taste
bitter and accurate and offline because
it's over extracted.
And that over extraction is what creates
tannins.
A,
right?
Well,
not tan and specifically,
but those,
that tannic sort of flavor,
it's makes us stringency,
flavor,
taste in your mouth,
and that bitterness is from the heat
itself.
Well,
it's extracting,
extracting bad tasting stuff out of the.
So it extracts
all the good tasting stuff.
But then there's an additional
extraction,
a bad tasting stuff too.
Fascinating.
yeah.
So you want to get the stuff that's like
loose.
there's like a ripe fruit,
right?
it's like right in the middle.
It's this sweet spot.
And so this organization that I worked
for called the specialty coffee
association,
we in the 19 fifties,
they started to do some science about
this and how to brew coffee properly and
get the coffee to our tasted best to the
most people and they had thousands of
people tasting different coffees,
you know,
and they determined what the perfect
extraction of a cup of coffee was to
most people in the,
in the world.
And um,
and then we,
then they designed a amount of
extraction.
So I'm going to get technical on you.
Okay.
So 100 night I already told you 195 to
200.
Five is the right temperature,
the extraction that you want to get is
between 18 and 22 percent extraction.
Now this is coffee geek stuff that
nobody wants to hear,
but this is the kind of stuff that we
talk to each other about.
Wow.
And,
and so,
uh,
and so like good.
If you have a favorite coffee place
where the baristas are like really good
and they make the coffee taste really
good,
chances are they know about that
extraction window and they're trying to
get the coffee within that extraction
window.
So it tastes great if you exceed 22
percent,
um,
and something closer to 30 percent of
the coffee is actually extractable,
you could get 30 percent of the material
out of the coffee if you want it,
if you totally squeezed the sponge dry,
but 18 to 22 percent is where it tastes
good.
WOw,
that's crazy.
It is.
Now you jumped at the chance to pour
this coffee and to brew this coffee or
something.
you didn't want us fucking it up?
Well,
yes.
it's true with good reason.
Neither jamie nor I know what the fuck
we're doing.
Was like,
he knows what he's talking about,
the dive,
I doubt it,
trust me,
he learned everything from me.
We know a little bit,
you know.
Um,
but when it comes to these sort of
things like times of extraction and
temperature,
does it vary depending on what kind of
coffee you have?
like,
so this is the ethiopian coffee,
would you have a different if it was a
jamaican?
Yep.
IT absolutely does.
And,
and so when,
um,
when coffee pros sort of start to work
with a coffee,
we'll experiment with different
temperatures,
different kinds of extraction,
different coarseness of grind to try to,
to try to get it right,
find the sweet spot.
Yeah.
We call it dialing it in.
So if we're like,
if,
if a,
if you're with a group of coffee people
and there's a new coffee,
you'll ask somebody,
did you dial it in?
And that means that means did you get it
tasting the way it should be tasting?
Wow.
So what are the variables?
Like what?
Like,
how much is the spectrum of variance
between say what's like an extreme given
extreme on each end of,
of what?
Of like brew times temperatures,
what's the difference?
Okay.
So every.
There's a.
FIrst of all,
there's a lot of different types.
Marley's yeah.
Yeah.
Stuff's delicious.
Thank you.
Um,
there's a lot of different.
Uh,
I'm gonna have a little more to smell.
Really unique.
Yeah.
It's really beautiful.
Clean,
clean,
floral coffee.
Yeah.
It's so different.
We usually have this a hawaiian stuff
lately.
Yeah.
A Hawaii roasters drinking.
That's really delicious.
Cool.
Yeah,
this is,
this is probably like the polar opposite
of that actually.
It's very different.
Smells amazing.
Yeah.
That's the thing about this coffee is
it's super fragrant.
Yeah.
In a very unusual way.
Like it doesn't smell like coffee.
It's almost like it's almost like tea.
Exactly.
right.
And that's,
I would describe this coffee is being t
like.
Yeah,
it's really beautiful.
And uh,
so anyway,
so there's all these different ways to
brew coffee.
So you've got a french press here,
there's a pour over coffee drip coffee
that you,
certain things,
but it was a little vacuum thing.
Uh,
you might be talking about an era.
Are those good?
Yeah.
Coffee people love them
and each one of those has a different
deal.
So like in this french press,
coffee will steep for awhile,
sort of like tea and then you press it
down and whatever.
And how long do you usually steep it?
four to six minutes is kind of a window.
Really?
Yeah.
Know how does something like a clover
work then?
Because the clover,
that crazy computerized coffee machine
that cooked at very quickly,
very quickly.
Right?
So the way that that works is it's
designed to be able to have fine,
finer coffee,
you know,
so um,
uh,
which changes the changes,
the extraction surface area,
right?
If you,
if you grind it really fine,
then it can,
it can brew,
it can extract really quickly.
so that's why like in an espresso
machine,
it's ground like to a powder.
Pull thAt video up of the clover
machine,
just so you can see what we're talking
about.
For folks who don't know,
some genius guys who were coffee nerds.
Sorry.
Yeah,
no vander nosler.
He's like,
yes,
I'm a coffee nerd.
I'm just under fdr,
but from stanford university,
and they figured out this machine which
costs some upwards of $10,000 dollars.
Yeah,
like 11,000 bucks and I've never thought
about buying one until I watched someone
do it and use it,
and I was like,
oh,
this might be the fucking coolest thing
ever.
Looked for a real coffee dork.
And then I found out that starbucks
bought them all those sons of bitches
and I don't even see them.
I never see them in a starbucks.
Oh yeah,
they have them,
but they're not that.
Well,
starbucks should fucking sell them.
I one of these for the office.
Tell it to you.
If they would,
I would be totally willing to buy one of
thoSe and just put it in this office.
I'll see if I can make that happen.
Then it happened.
The.
Yeah,
but I mean I used to have one in my
office,
so this is incredibly variable.
This thing,
if you've never seen it,
is this really beautifully constructed,
it looks like a giant Piston,
like a car engine piston and you pour
coffee in it and the water in it and
then you stir it with like a little
whisk
and then dial in the coffee based on the
known recipes for that
coffee.
Right,
exactly.
and so.
And it was made really fancy.
You hear it?
Yeah.
It could communicate with other machines
and you could send the recipe from one
machine to another.
Oh,
that's creepy.
They're going to take over.
Yeah.
Coffee machine is going to take over and
at the end it's really unusual.
It leaves this hockey hockey puck of
griNds at the top of the machine and
then you have this squeegee which is
kind of an elegant way to deal with that
little problem of what do you do with
the coffee grinds and they come off that
piston yet,
but it comes up like a cheeseburger.
It's so weird looking burger,
coffee,
break,
break out.
We call it and then you slide it in with
this little like gas station,
windshield washer,
squeegee thing.
Yep.
It's fucking bad ass.
Yeah.
And so on the.
So the reason that that can happen so
quickly is because you can use fine
coffee because it's got that hydraulic
piston that sort of pushes it up that's
incredibly strong.
It's got these,
these,
this metal filter that the coffee
grounds kind of sit on top of.
And so it's a pressurized situation
somewhere in the same realm as,
as uh,
the aircraft we were talking about
something similar.
And by the way,
the aero press is essentially a home,
you know,
$50 version of that
and it's just as good and.
Yeah.
Alright,
fuck the clover then jesus christ,
we almost,
we just saved ourselves 11 grand or
whatever it is.
Yeah.
That was really designed for like a
coffee service and bad ass though,
man,
of that kind of technology.
The fact that they want to support them,
they were willing to go out and invest
the money to make something like that
and design it.
Have you seen that?
The steam punk,
yet there's,
okay,
there's all these great coffee machines
out there that pulled out of steam,
pull it up.
And,
uh,
and this is,
recently,
uh,
designed machine and it's got,
it's got these glass tubes and bubbles
and you know,
all this crazy shit.
You're,
you're,
you're gonna love it.
When,
what is,
what is the benefit of that machine?
It's just another,
um,
it,
it actually works on a very similar
principle to all these things.
Um,
but they're,
all coffee machines are designed to make
it easier to do what I said before,
the,
uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's it.
That's the steam punk.
So that's that.
All each of those looks like a pirate
chambers.
Yeah.
Each of those chambers brew coffee.
Whoa.
Um,
and uh,
now interestingly,
you might get a computer,
a computer screen.
Yeah.
It's.
And that computer screen is to dial in
all these,
all these variables,
you know,
so recently out of the clover.
Too much pressure.
Yeah.
That's a question that's like asking me
what my favorite child is.
Sorry,
I probably can't play favorites.
No,
but it's right up there with clover.
Yeah,
absolutely.
How much has that been a thing?
That's a good question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I would guess in the same sort of range,
but,
and all of these things.
Now I'm going to tell you something
else,
which is these,
these machines,
all they do is make it easier to brew
coffee like this.
So you've got,
you've got some pretty sophisticated
equipment in your kitchen and this is
all what he's doing right here.
This was the right stuff.
Wow.
This is wild,
man.
This makes me feel like a scientist
though.
I'd like to have that.
It's kind of laboratories.
It was very mad scientists and so the
water's boiling and one of them and then
the coffees and the other one.
Is that what's going on here?
Well,
the one in the middle is kind of getting
ready.
He's going to dump some coffee in there.
He's in the one on the right.
It's already extracting the coffee and
these little,
those little up pistons are there to
sort of be the filters of the coffee.
It's a complicated machine.
And I would say so a couple of weeks ago
heRe in los angeles,
there was a,
uh,
there was a battle between,
um,
a guy called nick show.
Nick cho is the,
is the guy who,
he's one of the owners of this coffee
company who arrested this coffee,
we're drinking,
and then the inventor of that machine,
the,
uh,
the steam punk went head to head and had
like a man versus machine kind of thing.
And nick was just using very simple
little brewer that he poured the water
on,
just totally manual.
And then the other guy was,
was,
uh,
was use manning the steam punk and they
were like having this head to head where
they each had to brew six different
coffees for these three judges and they
couldn't see what they were drinking all
this stuff.
And uh,
now the,
the.
So the result was that the steam punk
machine won by a hair.
It was essentially a tie that the,
uh,
um,
and the point is that you can,
you can make coffee delicious by being
really good at mastering the variables,
knowing what your,
you're knowing what grind looks right,
knowing how hot the water is,
et cetera,
or you can interest that stuff to a
machine.
And that's what machInes do.
They just get the water right every time
they get the,
what we call the turbulence,
like how much it gets stirred right.
Every time.
And if you can replicate something very
precisely again and again and again,
the coffee is going to be really good.
I get a sense
though that you're a purist and the you
prefer to use manual equipment.
Almost like if you drove a car,
you would want a manual gearbox.
Are you that guy?
I am that guy.
Well,
I told,
I told somebody.
Somebody was interviewing me for
something a while ago and I told them I
don't own a coffee machine in my house
and I don't that I have essentially the
same setup that you have a water boiler
that boils the water for me.
A good grinder.
I notice you have a good grinder in
there.
Um,
and uh,
some home style pouring,
you know,
I use a basically very cheap $30.
Do you have a friend that I have a
french press.
I usually use paper filter though,
just because I prefer the flavor.
Do you really?
Yeah.
Okay.
that's an interesting thing to bring up
because I'm.
One of The things that I like about a
french press is when you get that sort
of bubbly surface and then when you pour
it into a mug,
you get kinda like a little phone like
that.
Do you still get that when you go
through a paper filter?
No,
that's exactly what it takes out.
That seems like that's a good thing.
It's good thing to you and that's great.
so you know,
you don't like it flavor,
you know this.
Okay.
So we're tasting it now.
can you taste in your mouth how you feel
like there is?
You can still taste the coffee a little
bit.
Yeah.
And it'S coating your mouth,
sort of like as if you just drank a
glass of milk or something.
Okay.
So that's called body or after taste and
after taste.
Those,
those are technical coffee tasting
terms.
Um,
and so body is the feeling,
the texture of the coffee in your mouth.
And aftertaste is the flavor of the
coffee that remains in your mouth once
you're gone.
Once it's gone.
And aftertaste especially is really
important because you drink coffee in
the morning and you're driving to work.
You still have that flavor of coffee in
your mouth.
If that's good,
then that's great.
Then you get,
you get an extra 20 minutes out of your
cup of coffee.
It's A bonus.
If it's bad,
if it's bad flavor and you feel like you
need a mint,
then that's like a bad after taste.
And so you either.
You're used to drinking good coffee.
You like that feeling in your mouth.
Do you like that flavor in your mouth?
You like aftertaste.
That's good.
You're brewing coffee the right way.
For me,
I,
I just tend to want to move on to the
next flavor,
whatever it is,
whatever.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're such a coffee geek.
You want to geek out with a bunch of
flavors in your mouth all day.
Wow.
You're taking it to a new level.
You went with a paper filter just to
remove aftertaste so you can move onto
the next flavor.
Couldn't you rinse it out with some
seltzer or something like that?
People do that.
Yeah.
Maybe some ginger like you do with
sushi.
Yeah.
Would that work?
I get.
Yeah.
I am.
Blood palate cleanser.
What?
You could do power plans or do you have
to brush your tongue or anything like
that in between?
People do.
There are people that scrape the tongue.
Man.
I don't do any of that mess.
That's the dark end of the pool.
People Where you can't see the bottom.
Yeah.
Your coffee geeking out in the woods.
Hardcore.
Whatever.
Yeah.
So this is a very delicious coffee and
you.
One of the things that I noticed is that
you,
um,
you serve it completely black.
You don't fuck around wIth coffee
filters or sugars,
but I mean genuinely coffee,
coffee people don't judge people that,
that do that.
Everybody [inaudible] to me.
I appreciate that.
That's really sweet.
Do you put stuff in your coffee?
Yeah,
usually.
Yeah.
Usually we will.
This is what I wanted you to try this.
This is a coffee mixed with grass fed
butter and mct oil.
I found about this from getting
familiar.
Yeah.
This is Hawaii roasters,
right?
I'll just.
Hawaii roasters,
rusty,
rusty.
Rusty's hawaiian.
And so,
um,
this,
uh,
I found out about this from this dude
dave asprey,
he calls it bulletproof coffee and
apparently a guy named rob wolf,
he was the first guy to figure it out.
What it is,
is coffee mixed with grass fed butter
and mct oil and then it's blended.
And the idea being that blending it all
up like that has you get all the healthy
fats,
make steam with the caffeine is sort of
a seat.
Well,
medium chain triglyceride oil,
it's like
palm oils and mostly coconut oils.
You take the spinning in a centrifuge
and extracted,
I don't know the exact process,
but it's essentially healthy fats and
then it's all mixed with this.
And the benefit of it is that because
it's all connected to the fats,
you get sort of a slow burn,
a slow release.
I get the impression from you though,
that you fucking hopped up on coffee all
day and a bunch of different kinds.
You don't need no slow release.
You just ride in that boat right into
the rocks.
It's interesting.
There was something you said earlier as
we were getting started,
you were talking about,
oh,
you were talking about the bars at the
top of the show,
you the meat bar or something like that?
Yeah,
yeah,
the warrior bar,
right?
The buffalo and cranberry.
So there's a story in coffee and uh,
we don't know if it's it,
if it's true or not,
but this is the legend is that in
ancient Ethiopia,
the ethiopian warriors would take the
fruits of the coffee.
So coffee grows like a fruit.
It's got,
you may have seen pictures.
It looks like a cherry.
Yeah.
And the two beans or like flat up
against each other,
like the pits of the cherry.
But around that is like a fruit layer,
like a sweet fruit layer.
The fruit tastes sort of like,
it's kind of slimy,
but it tastes like a mix of a,
of watermelon and jasmine.
And then there's a kind of a tough
leathery skin outside.
And the legend says that the ethiopians
would take that fruit and make a ball
with a animal fat in some stories,
say butter and other stories say like,
like,
uh,
um,
like cow fat,
and they would make balls out of them
and put them in there.
They're a packs.
And then just before a battle,
these warriors would eat this,
this like power bar thing,
and it was like fat from the,
from the,
uh,
from the animal fat to give you energy
and,
and kind of.
And then the sugar from the coffee fruit
to give that blast of energy.
And then the caffeine together.
Now some people say that this is like an
invented story.
Other people say that,
that you had no,
this is what the ancient ethiopians
actually did before,
before flight fighting a battle.
What is known is that the engine
ethiopians were known as,
especially intense warriors.
How come nobody has recreated this?
We need an on it coffee ball.
We need to make that right away.
That seems like something we need to.
But when he said,
when you said coffee and butter,
that's what I thought of is,
is,
is that kind of thing,
these coffee balls with butter?
Maybe.
Maybe that's what they're trying to kind
of recreate here.
I don't know.
Well,
um,
this was,
uh,
apparently the original people have been
putting,
gee,
you know,
it had been putting that in coffee for a
long.
But there was also like a yak t that uh,
the himalayans used to tibetans used
that was mixed with this yak butter and
t to make this creamy sort of a
concoction.
I like what I like about the mixing it
with the butter and mct oil is that it
gives you like a long lasting effect of
the caffeine.
Your body has to break down all those
fats and sort of blended in,
connected with the caffeine.
You don't get it as a big burst.
Like I drank this stuff because I
haven't drinking black coffee for a
while and with,
with nothing attached to it,
it's just like,
whew.
It just goes right into your system.
And you could,
you could feel yourself like pepping up.
Um,
how do you avoid heart attacks?
It's interesting.
Uh,
I a,
I don't,
don't worry about it.
No,
I'm just kidding obviously,
but yeah,
but you do get a rush from this.
This is some strong caffeine coffee.
This is some strong stuff.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess,
I guess I don't look good way.
I'm not criticizing.
No,
no,
no.
I know and it's really uniquely
delicious.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm kinda shocked.
My favorite coffee lately is this stuff
called rusty's hawaiian.
I've been drinkinG this a lot lately.
Arrestees?
Yeah.
oh god.
It's so good.
Yeah.
God,
that stuff is good.
I just,
something I really love about coffee
from the big island.
I don't know what it is,
but I had first tried hawaiian hawaiian
roasters is the red bag that somebody
told me about it.
Like,
dude,
you got to try a hawaiian coffee.
And so,
uh,
I got a hold this stuff a while back and
it's my all time favorite coffee just
has this like really sort of a um,
a,
a dark rich taste to it.
Very,
very different from this stuff.
This ethiopian stuff.
Yeah.
So different deal.
If coffee started there,
it started in Ethiopia.
Is that now,
did people take the plants and plant
them in other places?
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
So what happened was,
so the ethiopians were the first ones to
sort of discover coffee.
This is what we have here,
which we usually drink.
That's my favorite.
The one in the red bag.
That's what is it called?
It has a name though.
It's like it says here,
it says mocha peaberry from maui.
Yeah.
That's like a 94 on the coffee's so good
man.
Yeah.
But this is,
this is part of the story I can tell
you.
I can.
You were asking about coffee coming from
Ethiopia,
etc. Okay.
So,
um,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
This is cool.
They're really tiny,
really tiny.
And so,
um,
what happened was from the forests of
Ethiopia,
um,
on the,
on either side of what's called the rift
valley,
it's where it's,
where the human species evolved.
It's where we evolved over there and
coffee have all been in the same place.
So,
uh,
which is crazy to begin with.
And,
and,
uh,
the ethiopians consumed it somehow.
But then the,
uh,
somehow probably by the people on the
other side of the red sea and what's now
Yemen,
which was then called arabia felix,
this is like in,
uh,
about uh,
1100.
They said they said,
wait a second,
we got some,
some of the ethiopian slaves brought
some coffee seeds over there and they
started planting coffee in what's now
Yemen.
Um,
and they started growing it and it
turned into a big deal and they were the
first ones that actually expoRted it out
of the,
out of the area.
So,
um,
and the biggest,
the port,
the main port at that time in Yemen was
called mocha.
So
you've heard,
you know,
have a cafe mocha or coffee is called
mocha mocha,
mocha,
java,
all That stuff.
That's all a reference to this one port
in Yemen.
It's still there.
It's called alma alpaca.
And,
and,
um,
I thought mocha had something to do with
chocolate.
Yeah,
we,
we in the now in the states.
Yeah,
we kind of.
Well,
it's that people started adding
chocolate to coffee that wasn't from
there to try to make it taste like it
was from there.
So it had a natural chunk actually
chocolatey taste to it.
Can you still get coffee from you?
It's very hard because it's Yemen,
you know,
it's crazy.
And so yeah,
it's a difficult place to do business
and need to make friends with prince
naseem.
How mad do you remember that guy?
No,
he was a boxer from Yemen.
He did a lot of wild shit.
came in on a magic carpet.
Oh,
crazy.
He used to dance around the ring.
Yemen's an amazing place.
I mean I've,
I've never been there,
but I've seen lots of pictures.
I've known lots of yemeni people,
but it's just politically politically
dangerous.
Volatile.
But that's unfoRtunate.
It sounds like it's something unique
coffee out of there.
But so,
so anyway,
so they brought,
when they brought coffee for me,
Ethiopia tm and they brought only a few
plants and then they use those to be the
parents of all the,
the,
uh,
the coffee in Yemen and that they were
the ones that exported it anyway.
Then,
but then this is in history,
they were Growing coffee,
they were exporting it.
Other people said,
wait a second,
we want end on this coffee deal because
you're making money selling coffee,
but they had a.
They had a penalty of death if you got
seeds,
if you took seeds out of Yemen at that
time,
you got caught exporting fertile coffee
seeds you can be put to death.
It was that valuable,
that valuable.
That's incredible.
And this is at a time where when like
the english and the dutch were fighting
over the dutch east indies as the spice
islands,
you know,
people,
all these,
everybody was trying to get some
colonies going to export these cash
crops and they saw coffee as a potential
cash crop.
Some dutch spies successfully got some
coffee out of Yemen and they planted it
on and they had just won the war with
the english over the dutch east indies
and they planted the coffee that they
stole from Yemen in what's now Indonesia
on the island of java.
Wow.
And they turned that they did great.
They.
They planned it.
All these farms,
they were producing coffee and that's
why we still call it coffee java.
Wow.
So in mocha java,
mocha java is in,
you know,
150 years ago.
those were the two places
that made most of the coffee in the
world.
The port of mocha in Yemen and the
island of java in the dutch east indies.
Wow.
And Ethiopia back then,
like if that's where it all started
from,
they weren't exporting anything then
they were just like letting it go.
It would juSt eat drinking it
themselves.
Wow.
Yeah.
And they,
they didn't build an export market so.
So then it gets weirder.
You ready?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
the in the,
at one point the dutch and the french
signed a treaty and like,
uh,
you know,
some sort of treaty and as a gift the
dutch gave one coffee tree to the
french,
one coffee tree and the french in like,
uh,
in France they built a,
a hot house like a greenhouse just to
hold this plant.
And it was the first,
it was the first greenhouse in europe.
The first greenhouse in europe was for a
coffee.
Right.
And,
and they planted other stuff there too,
but this coffee plant was like really
special and,
and they used cuttings from that plant
to plant.
They wanted to plant some stuff in the
west indies and the caribbean.
Um,
they wanted to plant some coffee,
the french did to for their colonies.
And so this one guy named gabriela the
clue he was responsible for bringing the
coffee from France to martinique,
but so he brought this one plant and he
had it in a glass box,
but they ran out of wind on the journey
and the.
So they were stuck in the middle of the
atlantic ocean.
Gabriela,
the clue was sharing his water ration
with this plant to keep it alive.
Oh my god.
He managed to keep it alive,
planted it.
And that one plant was the parent of
most of the coffee in central America,
south ameRica,
etc. Holy shit.
Yeah.
So,
so now there's a scientific impact to
this because all the genetic diversity
that was in Ethiopia,
all the thousands of different coffee
varieties that were in Ethiopia.
Imagine how that got narrowed down from
getting a brought from Ethiopia tm in
the first place.
Then whatever plants those dutch spies a
stole to put the coffee in java.
Then that one plant that went to a,
that went to the new world that went to
France first and then to the new world
that's a,
they call it a genetic bottleneck,
so all the coffee outside of Ethiopia is
kind of siblings to one another.
That's incredible and that.
And that's a problem for us because if
there's a disease that,
that one genetic variety of coffee is,
is susceptible to,
it can wipe out the whole coffee deal.
it's so incredible that one particular
area of the world was the only place
where this stuff was growing and now
it's considered to be a completely
worldwide beverage.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And the ethiopians are kind of,
they're kind of pissed off about that.
Seriously.
If you go and you talked to them and
they're like [inaudible],
you know,
everybody says they've identified coffee
with columbia right now while fucking
one.
And they hate,
they hate one valdez and epo.
They're like,
that's our thing.
That's our thing that the world is
getting richard.
So,
um,
and,
but that's right.
I mean,
that's true.
If you go to Ethiopia,
the different kinds of flavors that you
can get in coffee from Ethiopia is crazy
compared to any anywhere else I was
saying was the genetic diversity genetic
diversity thing each,
each.
Uh,
each village in Ethiopia has their own
variety of coffee that they grow
traditionally.
Wow.
How many different varieties are there?
Well,
that's a good question.
We don't know completely.
They're still doing their scientists
that are out in Ethiopia right now
trying to count all the different coffee
varieties.
And the estimation is that there are
somewhere between three and 5,000
different varieties of coffee growing
wild in Ethiopia and outside of Ethiopia
there was like 30.
Why?
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's,
it's crazy.
That's nuts.
So every legit coffee connoisseur is
like a big fan of Ethiopia.
Do you have like in Ethiopia tee shirt
that you were in the spot?
It's like brazilian jujitsu.
Brazil is the spot,
right?
So you can pop up the origins center of
origin,
right?
If you want to get into taekwondo,
you go to Korea,
right?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's amazing man.
So,
um,
this particular blend that we had is
from Ethiopia and um,
what are the variables in ethiopian
coffees?
Like what's,
this is a,
sorry,
say the name again,
how you said you're a good chef.
You're a chef and a chef is a fruiTy
floral one,
but I would assume that with thousands
of different varieties you get a broad
spectrum of different flavors.
Right?
So,
so in,
so,
uh,
just north of,
of yoga chef is a kind of a larger area.
And actually you're a chef is within an
area called saddam is the name of the
region and we call coffees from there,
the dominoes dominoes are similar to
[inaudible] but they're not as floral.
They tend to be sweeter.
They tasted like honey to me.
So yeah,
they have a honey,
like,
like what's a good name for one if
someone wants to try one of those sidamo
any,
any sit donald.
And he spelled out house id.
A,
m o as any donald?
No.
Pretension.
Damo,
yeah.
Yeah.
There's different ones that,
that the,
that names that you get besides sidamo
will often be,
um,
uh,
or even yoga chef will often be the
specific name of a washing station will
wash the coffee itself.
And uh,
and so you can get geeky about that.
But sidamo is in what way?
Well,
you see people develop favorite,
favorite washing stations.
Yeah.
And what's the variables in the washing
process?
Changes the way the flavor is.
Yeah.
So,
um,
yeah.
And then I noticed I listened to a
podcast you did recently that had a
nutritionist and you've been talking
about washing,
washed coffee being important.
Yes.
And I thought I could explain that
process to you if you want me to.
Yes,
please.
Okay.
So it's all about how the,
I told you that coffee beans are like
two seeds inside of the cherry and you
got to get that fruit off because if you
don't get the fruit off it can mold and
spoil and tastes yucky.
So the whole challenge with coffee is
to,
is to do something with that fruit layer
before it spoils.
Okay.
And like,
because like any fruits of any kind of
fruit,
you pick it and then you either you
either do.
So whaT the ancient ethiopians did is
they just picked it and they set it on
the ground or on a mat to dry and the
and the,
the,
the coffee would sort of turn into
shrivel up,
turn into a raisin and once it was
totally dry,
they'd pound it in a mortar and pestle
and the seeds that would separate from
the dried up husk.
And then you could roast the seeds and
drink the coffee.
So,
um,
that was the original method of doing
coffee,
but when they moved coffee from
Ethiopia,
which is very warm and dry,
and they could,
they could grow it in Indonesia and in
central America,
but um,
and it grow fine.
But when they tried to dry it,
it was tougher because there's more rain
there,
it's more humid and the coffee would
mold and get musty and tastes crappy.
So in sent in Costa Rica,
they invented a different thing.
And what they did was they ran it
through a machine that would take strip
off the,
the,
the leathery skin.
Yeah,
well the leathery skin,
but it would leave this slimy fruit,
you know,
and it's sort of like,
if you eat a peach and some of the
right,
it sticks to the seed.
And that's exactly what happens to
coffee.
It's the sticky fruity stuff is sticking
to the seed and you got to get it off.
So what they did was they let it ferment
for about a day.
And if you let that stuff for men in a
bucket or a whatever,
a tUb for about a day,
then it,
it,
it looSened itself through magic.
It's like amaziNg.
It's,
it's,
uh,
the bacterial action and yeasts and
stuff act on that stuff to dissolve it.
And then you can wash it away with
water,
just rinses right off.
That's wet process,
that's wet processing.
And then once that sticky,
slimy,
sugary stuff is rinsed away,
then it's very easy to dry the coffee in
the sun.
It dries in a few days and then you can
husk it and send it for roasting.
So there's a difference between drying
it out and then roasting.
It must be dried out first and then it
must be roasted later.
Right?
Right.
So there's.
So in those two processes,
those two major processes,
or we call them either dry processing
and wet processing or the natural method
and the washed method,
so washed and and wet processing the
same thing
and dried and natural is the same thing.
So.
So in a certain way I'm changing
climates and moving coffee plants to
other geographic locations.
Presented a lot of pretty unique
challenges.
Absolutely.
For coffee they were doing in the 19th
century it seems so different than
anything else,
which is also a fruit that you would
grow me.
You would just take it when it's ripe
and you eat it when it's ripe,
but this seems like a really complicated
thing because what you're doing
student,
I mean unlike most fruits,
most fruits aren't cultivated for their
seeds.
Is there outside of the seed,
the isn't the abstract like the outside
doesn't have some sort of nutritional
benefit?
Sure.
Well it's,
I mean it's,
it's a fruit,
it's got sugar and it's got.
What does it taste like?
It tastes like I'm a.
I always say it's like a mixture of,
of watermelon and a jasmine real.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
It sounds delicious.
Delicious.
It's totally delicious.
You can't just buy coffee fruit.
Well you can.
The problem is that if they.
Coffee doesn't really grow around here.
Right?
So by the time they got it to you,
it'd be spoiled.
What do they do?
Here's a few things for you and I should
have brought some for you.
They,
they,
some places they keep the fruit that
they husk off and they drive that to a
and you can make sort of like a beverage
out of that by soaking that beverage in
water,
treating it like tea.
And they do that in Ethiopia and in
Yemen they call it has shara and Yemen.
They call it kesher.
And in,
in,
I mean sharon,
Ethiopia,
Kenya and Yemen.
And so it's another beverage that comes
from coffee and it's sweet and it's got
plenty of caffeine.
Really?
Yeah.
And uh,
and then more popular it seems like
that'd be more popular.
It's interesting.
you would think that that would be maybe
this new thing.
It's kind of.
Yeah.
What do you call it again?
Well,
a lot of places that sell it here,
call it c,
a,
s,
c,
a r a.
That's the spanish word for it.
Yeah.
Scada that now.
Is that what you said?
Starbucks could start selling.
They could,
yeah.
Why don't they do that?
That's a good question.
Fuck's wrong with you?
Starbucks.
Get on the ball.
Then she bitches like money.
But like there's some,
there's other coffee companies sell it
and it's good.
Yeah.
It's,
it's kind of an,
it's not satisfying in the same way that
coffee is,
it's kind of an oddity you'll,
you'll try it.
Yeah,
I certainly will.
Yeah.
You tell me what that sounds
interesting.
Coskata.
Okay.
I gotta remember that now.
The,
the actual beiNg itself.
Is there more caffeine in the fruity
outer layer or is there more caffeine in
the bean itself?
I don't know
the answer to that.
Okay.
But there's theory and there's coffee.
That's true.
It varies.
And the,
and uh,
there's caffeine in all parts of the,
the coffee plant,
the leaves,
everything.
Yeah.
It's there and everybody even look like
I don't even know what it looks.
Um,
it's about,
well,
it depends on the variety of coffee,
but generally they're about eight feet
tall at the bush.
Yeah.
All I know about that as now that I'm
realizing it's fucking Juan Valdez,
man.
Juan valdez.
The only why they did they really got
attached to that burrow and him with his
coffee beans.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
How odd now
is there a variation in the caffeine
content of beans from one part of the
world to the other?
Because I've seen something called
kicking horse that was called kicking
horse coffee claims to have super
excessive amount of caffeine.
Yeah,
I,
well,
I don't know that brand,
but what they might be talking about is
there's another species of coffee.
So I'm.
so there's the species that we've been
talking about from Ethiopia and all that
stuff is called cafe.
Arabica is the name of that spa.
Okay.
So theRe's another species that comes
from the western part of africa and um,
it's called cafe canephora,
but we call it robust.
Have you ever heard of her breasts?
Okay.
So robust.
It comes from west africa.
It doesn't taste as good generally.
Um,
it's uh,
it,
it's sort of my,
in my experience,
it tastes like burnt popcorn,
you know,
cheap diner coffee has that burden,
popcorn kind of taste to it.
That's from the robust data in it.
And they've used burnt popcorn.
Yeah.
Rubber star diner in white plains,
dr.
Totally.
I used to eat it this fucking place.
Their coffee was just always like burnt
popcorn.
I didn't even thought of that,
but it tasted like shit.
Yeah.
So that's the robusta in it.
Never bust.
That has a lot more caffeine than,
than,
than arabica does.
No kidding.
But it also has a bunch of other
chemicals that don't taste very good.
uh,
so that's why it's got such a jolt to,
it tastes like shit.
So some
people I've seen people talk about high,
you know,
high caffeine coffee and they're just
using robust enough to sort of,
to sort of amp up the,
the,
uh,
the caffeine level,
let's I think floating around.
That's the scoop scoop.
I didn't take it up and jamie were
drinking plastic soup here.
Um,
the uh,
but you know,
I mean obviously caffeine is an
important part of the deal without it
the fit,
let's be honest,
this is a drug.
The ride wouldn't be nearly as a line
list nearly as long.
It's true.
Yeah.
But,
but
after that,
once you've satisfied the caffeine,
you know,
part,
um,
you start drinking coffee for what it
tastes like and so,
and so people that are focused on coffee
flavor tend to deemphasize the jolt part
and,
and emphasize
the flavor,
the flavor part.
What is the,
the orange,
why does the plant produce caffeine in
the first place?
Is that we know that?
Yeah,
it's an
called an alkaloid is the,
is the,
uh,
class of chemical.
The caffeine is.
And uh,
and there's,
in general,
plants seem to,
to produce alkaloids to drive away,
um,
predation.
Yeah,
like insects and stuff like that.
Okay.
so the insects eat the coffee,
have a fucking heart attack,
follow scott that's toxIc to insects at
a micro level.
So the animals,
a lot of animals as well.
Right?
But from what I understand,
that's the reason why dogs don't like
chocolate.
We shouLd feed your dog chocolate.
It's another alkaloid called
theobromine.
So,
um,
so theobromine
chocolate has and it's very similar to
caffeine.
It'll make you your heart.
You know,
and I talked to a veterinarian about
this once and the problem with,
with dogs is they eat a bunch of
chocolate and their heart pounds so
fast.
They have a heart attack.
Yeah.
From the,
from the,
uh,
theobromine and it's like caffeine and
in,
you know,
people say that,
that uh,
the chocolate has caffeine,
that active thing is actually feel
bromine,
which is.
So it's an alkaloid,
it's very similar.
It's a stimulant that works on dogs in a
different way that it works on humans.
Yeah.
It's the dogs are more susceptible to
it.
That's fascinating because in humans it
actually has some weird like
representation of love.
Right?
It gives a very similar,
if they say yeah.
Yeah,
just kind of makes sense.
Right?
They give chocolate to people.
Yeah.
Then that's what they say.
I mean,
my,
myself,
if I drink,
if I eat too much chocolate,
my heart pounds,
I can feel it much,
much more than.
Well,
you're a hairy dude.
You're probably much more animal.
Like a.
There was a recent article that I was
reading today online about chocolate.
That chocolate is going to be extremely
rare in the future because of our,
um,
our overconsumption of chocolate.
We consume so much chocolate.
They can't keep up with the production.
The demand can't keep up,
keep up with the production
and they've got a similar product,
project problem that coffee does.
So,
so genetic problem or genetic problem
and,
and uh,
and the same.
Okay.
So chocolate is indigenous to south
America.
I'm like,
coffee is indigenous to africa.
A cacao is from latin America and uh,
but then it's been spread all over the
world has a narrow genetic base.
I mean,
all these tropical crops have these,
have these problems.
The other problem is climate change.
Um,
you know,
as the climate gets warmer,
these,
the,
the suitable kind of environment for
these very climate,
very temperature intolerant plants,
narrows diseases spread more easily,
etc. Etc.
It's a problem
that is very interesting.
So you said that coffee can't be grown
in the United States?
Well,
it can.
Mainly.
Hawaii is in the United States,
in Hawaii.
Um,
there is also one farm here in
California,
really up in santa barbara.
It's not far.
You can drive here in santa barbara.
Yeah.
How's their coffee?
Delicious.
Real?
Yeah.
And heat.
But he only planted this farm a few
years ago.
No shit.
Yeah,
it's called good land organics.
So he's the only guy in America and
these growing coffee in the lower 48.
Yeah.
Yep.
And it's because he's in a very unique
kind of microclimate there.
There's actually,
if you go to his farm,
it can be warmer at night on this farm
than it is during the day because of the
weird way that the weather works around
their santa barbara's paradise.
It is,
it's beautiful.
It's amaZing.
This place you should,
you should go to this farm should.
He also grows amazing fruits like,
uh,
these,
these crazy australian lines called
finger limes that are looked like caviar
inside chair.
A moya says.
Have you ever heard of chairman?
Yes,
they are very rare.
Tropical fruit.
No.
Never heard of that.
Grows all these insane fruits.
Wow.
What's the name of his place?
Good land organics.
That's pretty cool that he's the guy
that,
uh,
figures out how to grow coffee autos.
He has there.
So there's a lot of avocados in santa
barbara.
So he,
he,
he got this avocado.
He's a,
he's a guy from hearing it.
I think it came from the here in la and
he got into agriculture and he bought
this farm that was an avocado farm.
But then he started planting dragon
fruit.
These finger limes.
I'm ciara moya is all this stuff and he
grows coffee there.
Um,
and he just like a really good fruit
grower and he grabbed his coffee and,
and he,
uh,
he was telling me recently he's,
I mean,
this coffee that he grew,
he's planted the right varieties of
coffee,
including this one,
the moca variety that has these little
tiny beans.
Um,
he's got that growing there,
etc. And it's just now coming into
fruit.
You know,
one of the interesting things about
coffee as you plant a coffee seed,
you don't start to harvest coffee from
between three and seven years after you
planted.
Wow.
So he's just now starting to reap the
rewards of all these years and years of
taking care of plants.
That is fascinating.
Yeah.
Dude,
you should grow coffee.
You love it so much.
Why are you not involved in growing it?
Well,
yeah,
maybe someday spot in santa barbara,
a small patch of land in santa barbara
and let the party begin.
I would love it.
I,
I've,
I've always traveled too much to like be
at a,
at a farm.
So I mean,
I've spent the last
15 or so years just traveling to coffee
farms all over the world,
working with coffee farmers to get their
quality better and,
and,
uh,
and kind of learn about all this stuff
because that's kind of a new phenomenon
to his,
his coffee roasting companies that are
interacting more directly with farmers
and getting the,
you know,
getting the quality thing really worked
out.
UnderstandIng,
um,
what makes coffee grade.
Yeah.
So most farmers that are growing coffee
the,
are they doing it just for a profit or
there's other places where you go in
there,
real artisans.
Is there a broad variation?
It's mostly the first thing because most
of the artisans.
No,
no,
it's mostly businesses.
It's mostly,
well it's mostly the
small farmers struggling to get by.
So,
so going back to the history,
so the dutch,
you know,
they planted their thing in java and
they basically enslave the local
population to work on their,
on their coffee farms.
This is in the,
you know,
in the 18th century,
the,
everybody was,
all the european were trying to get
colonies everywhere.
So,
you know,
colonies,
the spanish during their colonies in
central America,
the french doing their colonies.
And in west africa,
the english we're trying to colonize
Kenya,
the,
uh,
the dutch were colonized east India and
they,
they kind of enslaved the local
population to grow coffee and,
and,
and so,
uh,
and so that was sort of a dark period
in,
in world history.
And unfortunately coffee was part of
that.
But since then,
so then,
you know,
the enlightenment happened.
A democracies started to spread around
the world,
but still many of these countries that
were former former colonies were,
had poverty problems like central
America and stuff like that.
Um,
the place that I started first started
working with coffee farmers was in
Nicaragua and in Nicaragua was formerly
a colony,
you know,
and,
and had that problem,
but then they had the revolution.
They,
they,
uh,
they dissolved a lot of these big farms
and gave little parcels of land to a lot
of people that used to work on the farm.
So here you have all these people that
used to work on a farm that now have
their little tiny farm of them have
their own and that's cool because then
they've got,
you know,
they've got their own business,
their farm that's going.
The problem is it's pretty tough in any
country,
whether it's the United States or
Nicaragua or anywhere to make a small
farm profitable.
And so in many,
many parts of the world,
you've got small farmers that are just
trying to get by,
you know,
and put food on their plate.
And so one of the,
one of the great things that coffee that
special coffee companies can do is get
engaged with those farmers and try to
get the,
the,
celebrate the product,
get people to pay more for it because it
tastes really delicious and it becomes a
better livelihood for farmers all,
uh,
all across the world.
So your friend in santa barbara,
what was his name again that owns this
place?
J rescue is his.
And what's the name of the place again?
Good land organics.
And so he's just a guy who loves coffee
and decides I'm going to try to grow
some stuff in santa barbara.
It's growing.
He's,
he loves agriculture growing.
And he thought it was a challenge to
grow coffee,
I think.
I think he loves coffee too,
but I think really he loved the fact
that it was a challenge to the likes,
these unusual fruits.
So it kind of takes a person with a sort
of a deep commitment to,
to make something like this take place.
Otherwise it's a pretty significant
investment in time and effort before you
reap any rewards.
And there are those people
two in coffee.
I mean even in,
you know,
in,
uh,
El Salvador and Guatemala.
I'm in Panama in Brazil.
I know if I know of like amazing farmers
and all of these places who are like
focused on like making the best
imaginable coffee.
So now when you work with these people,
say if somebody contacts you and say,
peter,
I know what the fuck I'm doing.
Come down here and help me grow some
bitch and coffee.
Yeah.
What is your process like?
Let's say a guy from Hawaii calls you
up,
says,
I want to grow some coffee.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Yeah,
well coffee is kind of an unusual.
I mean,
Hawaii is kind of an unusual situation
because the university of Hawaii is
involved and they can actually call it
the university of Hawaii and get.
So they wouldn't,
they wouldn't need me.
Okay.
So where would they need you at south
America?
Peru.
busted for cocaine
the first.
Yeah.
And Peru.
I've done a lot of work in Peru and
Bolivia and,
and uh,
and not just me.
I mean there's lots of choice.
Lots of,
of people out there and,
and,
and in fact that the us government
through usa id is out there trying to
give a,
give good support to these guys.
The first thing you do is you teAch,
teach them to taste coffee and
amazingly,
and some of your listeners may may have
had this experience.
I've had this experience.
You go to wherever and Nicaragua,
Costa Rica,
Peru or whatever place that's famous for
its coffee and you go into the hotel and
they've got nice cafe and the instant
coffee in the restaurant or whatever.
And it's because a lot of these places,
people don't drink the coffee,
they grow the coffee,
but they don't drink it.
And it's crazy.
That's so weird.
totally weird.
How's that happen?
Because it's more valuable to export so
they don't drink it just because it's
not worth it.
It's worth it.
That's part of the culture that's
interesting now.
So not part of the culture yet.
It is,
it is.
It's part of the agricultural culture,
but it's not part of the consumption
culture.
It's weird.
Okay.
A Ethiopia is the only place in Brazil
to some extent,
um,
where they drink coffee as much as they,
as they,
as they exit
47.
Brazil has the same issue.
The rest of south America where they
have a very limited genetics.
And is that the same or different?
Because Brazil is so much bigger,
but they're more than one variety from
Russia in general.
But um,
and,
and all of these countries,
by the way,
are aware of this problem and they're
trying to diversify their genetics.
So do they contact you through the
coffee website?
Is specialty coffee association of
America
in the,
uh,
yeah,
so in the,
uh,
about starting in 2000 or so we,
we,
uh,
we in our group that were affiliated
with,
called the coffee quality institute,
put had this program called coffee core.
It's sorta like the peace corps for
coffee people and guys like me would,
would,
uh,
would sign up and volunteer for two
weeks to serve in a coffee farming
community.
And if we had a skiLL,
we might have marketing skill or,
or,
uh,
aCcounting or tasting.
My,
my Skill was tasting.
So I would go down,
I would teach a coffee cooperative in El
Salvador.
Do you speak spanish?
yes.
Oh,
okay.
How to taste their coffee and taste it
like we do,
you know,
look for things like sweetness and
flavor and aroma and stuff like that.
And just that is like extremely powerful
because if you're running a coffee farm
and you and you know how to taste it,
like your buyer is going to taste it and
then you can say,
all right,
this case,
it's better.
I'm going To do this,
I'm going to grow it this way,
I'm going to dry it this way,
I'm going to ferment it this way,
etc.
Now when you say grow it this way,
what are the variables involved in
changing the flavor of coffee?
Is it just climate or is it the soil
content or is it something that you add
to the soil the way you water them?
What do you do?
Well,
most of them
biggest thing is the climate and a lot
of that is determined by altitudes.
So remember mrs.
Mrs. Owen on folgers.
What was the lady?
I don't know.
Anyway,
I'm a commercial.
She used to say mountain grown folgers.
Oh that's right.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
and That's because coffee likes to be at
high altitudes.
So in general,
the higher the altitude the farm is,
the better the coffee and then.
But a farmer has no control over the
altitude of their,
their farm,
but what they can control is how much
shade that the,
uh,
the coffee gets.
So they plant trees next to the coffee
to actually provide some shade for it.
Really.
So they have coffee and they're like oak
trees or some shit.
Yeah.
Usually it's a different.
They're different.
They're like latin american indigenous,
something that large leaves shady.
Yeah.
And,
and,
uh,
and sometimes it's a fruit tree so they
can get fruit as well from the or other
j is avocados in,
in,
uh,
in santa barbara for this.
Wow.
Okay.
So he grows his avocado trees and then
sandwiches them inbetween.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
so the deal is
the coffee now a shaded coffee.
So coffee evolved under other trees.
It's called an understory shrub.
It,
it,
it naturally likes to be protected by
the trees.
However,
if you take it out and put it in the
full sun,
it will be more productive.
It'll produce a lot more coffee.
But in general that coffee won't be as
good.
So if a farmer has to like figure out
the benefit,
you know,
it it,
if he puts it in shade,
the coffee will taste better,
but it won't be as productive.
So he has to sort of balance and that's,
that's what happens in coffee all the
time,
you know,
it's like the better you make it taste,
the less there is of it kind of thing.
And so a farmer is always trying to make
that balancing act between having this
far and be more productive versus having
the quality
I hire.
What is the ultimate taste expression?
What is the move to get?
Forget about no money involved.
No,
no financial reward.
You're only trying to achieve the
greatest taste ever.
What's,
what's the way to do that?
Start with a variety of coffee that's
known for being really good tasting.
So there's these different varieties of
coffee that we talked about.
Some of them tastes really good,
some of them maybe are more disease
resistant and don't taste as good
because of that.
So you choose a good,
a good
variety to start with.
The disease resistant coffees don't
taste as good as the thing.
And what diseases specifically is it
getting there is a disease in and you
may have heard about it in the news.
It's actually a big deal right now.
It's called coffee rust and it's a
fungal disease that it makes the coffee
leaves,
get this powder on them that looked
exactly like rust makes all the leaves
fall off and the coffee plant.
So is it similar to like,
what's going on?
Like,
like,
um,
what is that disease that was hitting?
Oh no,
that was the bark beetle.
I was thinking of a bug.
But it's like that in that,
in that,
uh,
you know,
these,
these crops can be susceptible,
particularly if there's a narrow genetic
we were talking about and what,
what specific?
Where's this coffee?
Rust,
like what is the,
uh,
is it all over the world or is.
Yeah,
it's all over the world except it
doesn't occur really in,
in Ethiopia.
So there's some sort of natural control
happening in Ethiopia that seems to be
the motherland,
is that like.
So if you're a real coffee dork,
you're going all due respect.
Yeah.
I mean that in a good way.
I get it,
if you're a real coffee connoisseur,
Ethiopia is the spot.
That's where you want to get your
coffee.
This for the strongest flavors,
the widest variety of flavor and because
it's the,
oh gee,
I think so.
You know,
but then you know,
not to qualify that too much.
I mean there's amazing coffees from
central America.
Colombia has some of the most incredible
coffees and they're very different.
Crazy diversity.
Yeah.
In Hawaii,
like I said,
I really enjoy a coffee from Hawaii.
It just seems to me to have a very
different taste as well.
What causes that?
Is it the volcanic ground and be a.
And then coffee's within Hawaii too can
taste very different.
There's a,
there's a,
uh,
this is a maui coffee and I usually like
to kona coffees.
Yeah.
Kona is the most well known area on the,
it's on the big island,
you know,
um,
and then it's got altitude.
you can,
once you go up that mountain,
that's the biggest challenge in,
uh,
in Hawaii.
I used to know some people that managed
the coffee farm in molokai,
which is a smaller island,
not as much altitude.
The coffee wasn't as good,
so that's interesting.
Yeah.
There's a place in,
in,
in Hawaii and on the big island called
mountain thunder.
Have you ever heard of this thing?
No.
Great.
Great coffee from mountain thunder from
the big island,
the big island.
Really delicious.
I'll get in there.
Yeah.
But anyway.
Um,
but in general coffees from islands,
like a,
like a Hawaii,
Jamaica,
places like this,
they've got a kind of a unique
characteristic.
You mighT like coffee from,
uh,
from Indonesia,
from papa new Guinea.
And this stuff has four stars.
yeah.
Uh,
Indonesia and papa new Guinea.
You know,
I,
I really enjoy coffee,
but until this conversation I was a
full.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
fool.
I knew nothing.
I relied on too many unscrupulous people
to fill my head with useless
information.
This is what we do in coffee people.
This is what we do.
We get dial in to what people like
and,
and you know,
show them other options if they want.
So to continue what I was asking you
before,
say if someone contacted you from Let's
say somewhere in south America and they
wanted you to go over there and hey,
we need to fix our flavor profile,
what would you do besides planting
trees?
Step one is start tasting the coffee
themselves and,
and how can you,
how can you change that taste?
Well,
okay.
So you can either shade the coffee or
not.
You can,
you can,
you can.
One easy way that a farmer can change
the quality of their coffee is how ripe
it gets.
So as coffee gets riper,
it gets sweeter obviously,
but you don't want it to be too sweet or
else it'll get like overly sweet.
And also we'll get this kind of rotten
character.
So figuring out dialing.
And there was a farmer I worked with in
El Salvador,
um,
uh,
who like got super focused on how ripe
she was going to pick her coffee and she
wind up figuring out this is good.
This is geeky and amaZing is that if she
let the coffee get half of the coffee
you get to get ripe to where it was,
the color of blood,
uh,
or I'm sorry,
of wine,
right?
Like burgundy color,
and then half of the coffee cherries get
to where they were.
The color of blood,
like bright red like this.
Um,
and blended those together.
It was the perfect flavor.
wow.
What a dork.
And she dialed in,
but she's famous.
They did a,
uh,
a uh,
her name is aida by eight.
They did a,
uh,
a piece on her in the new yorker a
couple years ago because she's become
the rockstar of,
in the coffee world.
That's so fascinating to me.
Like I said,
when you sat down,
I love people that are really industry.
When someone gets really into something
as you are in a coffee,
it's very infectious.
Like,
you know,
I want to like start trying all these
different flavors now,
but I don't want to be hopped up out of
my fucking mind on caffeine all day.
Well,
you don't have to drink that much
either.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
I've already drank five cups of this
space it out a little bit,
but it's really good,
but if you go to a coffee shop all the
time,
they can blow your mind with a different
flavor of all times.
How do you feel about a place like a
chain,
like a big chain?
We don't even have to mention any names,
but one of those big chains that cells
sort of generic coffee like does that.
you're talking about starbucks.
I am talking about starbucks.
Does that make you sad when you see
these fucking things are popping up all
over the place now?
Well,
let me tell you a story.
So I started in coffee in san diego.
I was running a coffee shop in the.
I started in [inaudible] 87.
Right.
So I was a barista in the early nineties
and stuff and in 1994 we're running this
coffee shop in san diego and we got word
that starbucks was going to start
opening stores in san diego and
everybody freaked out like,
oh my god,
we're done.
We might as well,
you know,
they're going to.
They're going to drive us into the
ground that the year that starbucks
showed up,
um,
was the busiest year that we had and
every year after that got busier and the
great.
So the great thing that starbucks has
done and starbucks is,
you know,
they,
they started in the seventies in
seattle,
a bunch of guys that really liked coffee
and they just,
they just figured out how to grow this
business.
Um,
uh,
they taught in many ways.
They taught the world how to drink
coffee.
They taught the world to drink coffee in
many ways.
When I was a kid,
we used to drink coffee in the morning,
like before I would go to work or you
know,
like um,
guys would go to dunkin donuts and I was
working on construction job sites.
Guys are good at dunkin donuts or bring
back coffees for everybody.
Yeah.
But there was no,
like going to a coffee shop and buying a
coffee in the middle of the day.
That Sort of starbucks shifted people's
mentality,
shifted their behavior to shit.
Like brian,
like he's,
oh,
the guy was here earlier.
It was always gotta fucking venti coffee
in his hand where he goes,
he's got to starbucks.
That's right.
And so and so,
and that's important,
you know,
so,
uh,
they've,
you know,
they've grown and gotten very ubiquitous
and stuff.
They've got shops all over the place,
but it's not that delicious.
It's not the best stuff.
It's,
well,
I mean,
you know,
I know you're trying to be nice.
I don't want to accuse anybody of
anything but okay,
let me put it this way in a very nice
way.
Instead of saying something negative
about them,
which I use all the time.
By the way,
I'm not going to starbucks hater.
I,
I buy starbucks all the time.
I have no problem with it.
And um,
if you were going to look for a very
specific,
very gourmet type of coffee,
that's not where you would go.
I'm not a bad cup of coffee,
not a bad cup of coffee.
But if you want to go really,
you want to have some of this stuff and
have it this way,
I wouldn't go to a starbucks store
because that's not what they're doing.
They're bringing coffee to the people,
they're bringing back up pike's peak and
maybe a dark roast.
And that's it.
And I will say though that I've tasted,
I've been to starbucks where they blow,
you know,
whether they've got access to awesome
coffees and they do have that.
They do do that.
It's not in every store,
kind of.
Right,
right.
You know,
we'll have the clovers now.
Uh,
yeah.
They've got the clovers,
they never seen one In a starbucks.
Yeah.
They've got them in special stores in
and uh,
and that's another thing that they're
doing.
They're starting to,
uh,
you may have seen it in the news.
They're designing different stores that
do different things and,
and they're,
they're,
you know,
they're a specialty coffee company
that's doing their thing and they do
have a wide variety when you bought
bags.
Yeah.
Got,
like limited small lot stuff that they
do.
And how should you store coffee?
We put it in the freezers that bad.
Uh,
it depends.
it can be bad,
it can be bad if your freezer stinks and
you don't,
you know,
you don't seal the bag up well enough.
No,
we don't have a stinky freezers then
you're good.
we don't ever put anything in there.
But coffee.
Yeah.
One.
And the other problem is like right now
we took the,
we took the coffee out and it got him to
room temperature and you take it like if
you take a coffee mug that's in the
freezer out,
you put it in your thing,
it gets All wet on the
outside.
Right.
Then you've got that problem,
you know,
in general we don't tell people.
We generally encourage people not to put
it in the freezer just and just drink it
fast.
Okay.
So I will say that if I was on,
if I was in Alaska or something,
you know,
and I could only get a shipment of
coffee once every six months,
I would freeze it.
Oh,
okay.
But,
but ideal,
I don't.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's not ideal.
So you should essentially,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but you should essentially do it almost
like you buy vegetables so you
shouldn't.
exactly.
I always say like you buy bread so you
should get it and between the time that
it's dried and between the time that
it's roasted and then you drink it,
how much time should it take place
between the time it's roasted and the
time you drink it?
So the dry,
it's essentially,
it's good for how long.
Once it's drawn,
once it's dried and in Nicaragua or
whatever,
then it's usually good for about a year,
a year.
And that's good because it's about once
a year,
you know,
coffee,
coffee harvest happens once a year.
They dry it all,
they get it together,
they stabilize it by drying and then
they ship it to roasters in the us.
Okay.
So assuming you're in the correct window
then once you get it to a roaster,
uh,
how long after it's roasted,
should you drink it and does it matter
or should you brew it and does it matter
how it's stored?
Then?
Usually the window after roasting is
about two weeks,
two weeks only.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
Like bread.
Wow.
You know,
that's crazy.
And,
and really should roast to order.
Yeah.
And,
and so that's why,
you know,
a good that's interested in coffee
roasting company.
We have some old coffee.
We should just throw it away.
Yeah,
there's no point.
Just get some new coffee.
But I'm like this one,
it says,
it says when it was roasted.
Yeah,
right there.
Yeah.
So that's a,
that's a uh,
that's a good sign when a,
when a roaster cares enough to like put
the roasting date on there.
This shit was roasted just a couple of
days ago.
Yeah,
that's how you do it.
Huh?
And this is from wrecking ball wrecking
ball.
Whereas this company in san francisco,
san francisco is awesome.
Yeah,
of course they would have something like
this there.
Yeah.
And the uh,
the uh,
it's kind of a cool company to that.
The,
a couple owns this company,
she's like a kind of a legendary
roaster.
She's been in coffee for a long time and
uh,
and he is like a pretty famous barista
guy and they got together and they've
got kind of the,
the,
they're kind of a power couple in
coffee.
That sounds amazing.
Yeah.
They're breaking ball coffee.
All right.
I'm going to buy some of this.
You can buy it online.
And so when you buy it online,
do they roast it when you order it?
Yeah,
a good coffee coffee company will do
that.
They'll sort of collect the orders and
then and then do a roasting day and send
it out all out.
I have time she'd get it the day after
it was my friend has a coffee company
called caveman coffee and when you order
it from caveman coffee.com or whatever
the fuck it is,
they,
they roast it as you or that's cool.
That's the only way to do it.
Right.
Very cool.
And they should probably start including
roasted on dance.
Huh?
They don't have roasted on dates,
but that shit sounds like it's
important.
Sure.
well,
I mean if you're the bag or something,
I was making a decision about what
coffee to bring you today that made a
difference.
Dude,
you knocked it out of the park because
this is a unique flavor and it's,
it's different.
It's unique and weird.
Uh,
unexpected way.
You know,
I really,
really like it.
I love the smell of it too,
man.
What are the beans smell like?
Did they have a unique smell?
So you should get a little bit of a
whiff of that,
of that,
a low of that lemonade,
jasmine kind of thing.
Why don't they make sense out of this
shit?
I know,
right?
Smell so good.
You know,
I used to,
one time I had to,
I had to work with an airline to try to
get their coffee tasting better up
there.
They.
And how did you do that?
And you go,
I didn't.
It wasn't that successful in this.
In this particular case,
it wasn't that successful,
but with all the flight attendants were
doing is they were taking the coffee
bags and they're putting it in the
bathroom to make it smell a little bit
better in there.
That was the best thing that they couLd
do with this.
Oh,
so you just used it as coffee popery
yeah,
exactLy.
That's interesting.
Well,
that's kind of a good move beCause when
you smell,
even if it's crap coffee,
you know,
when you smell the grinds,
it smells good.
You can open up a folgers and get it
out.
That's folgers is crap,
but you get that,
that smell of non roasted the coffee.
It's delicious.
It's like so people,
human beings like the smell of brown
things,
you know.
Have you noticed at all brown things?
Yeah,
but like,
you know,
toasts.
Yes.
One of the greatest smells ever eat
steak.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
Good point.
Bread,
baking all these chocolate.
We love things that are a little bit
right.
Yeah.
This brown,
the column browning reactions in
science,
you know,
and when he turns food brown,
it tastes good.
It certainlY does.
It's fascinating thing.
Like try eating a piece of raw steak.
Yeah,
it really doesn't have that,
that great.
The best flavor to it,
but god damn when it's got that crust on
the outside of it and you cut through it
and.
Yeah.
Delicious.
I am a fan of tastes and flavors and I
think it's sort of an unsung art form
that people have figured out how to
cultivate different tastes and flavors
and all sorts of foods and I'm in in
cooking.
I became a big fan of cooking.
I can't.
I don't really cook very well,
but I became a big fan of the art form
of cooking very well when I started
watching anthony bourdain's no
reservations show and then and becoming
friends with him and getting to know him
and talking to him about chefs and going
to a restaurant with him,
which is what was one of the coolest
fucking experiences of all time is
amazing.
It's like,
you know,
playing basketball with Michael Jordan
or soda and you're hanging out at a
restaurant with anthony bourdain.
Totally.
But he,
you.
I developed a respect for the art form
from him,
from watching his show,
the art form of cooking,
and then I started considering it in a
different light instead of thinking
like,
oh,
it's nice when people cook good food.
Oh,
that tastes good.
I want to eat there instead.
I started thinking of it as art is
artwork right now.
No different than a song.
No different than a standup comedy
sketch or you know,
or a cup of coffee.
Right?
The,
the,
the art in the creative,
the creative.
Literally creative because you're
creating.
I mean,
you're growing and you're,
you're,
you're influencing the actual finished
product.
Yeah.
It's sort of an overlooked aspect of
creativity,
isn't it?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It totally is.
And,
and people,
it's nice to hear you talking like that
because guys in coffee,
if we start to talk about how we think
of coffee as an art form,
a lot of times people are like,
ah,
come on,
you.
People are always looking to call
bullshit man.
People call bullshit too much.
It's true.
It's good thing to call bullshit because
there's a lot of bullshit out there,
but it's not a good thing to call
bullshit about people's passions.
I think it's more interesting to observe
those passions and try to find out what
it is and if I looked at it on a surface
level and I wasn't really into flavors
and I didn't have that sort of
transition in the way I thought about
flavors because of cooking,
I probably wouldn't think about it that
much either.
But when I sit down and talk to a guy
like you who obviously is dedicated,
incredible amount of time to this
passion,
then that's when it becomes infectious.
You kind of understand it.
Yeah,
it's true.
So,
um,
and that's the way I,
you know,
I,
and a lot of my colleagues think about
it is,
is like how can we make the flavor just
kind of stopped people in their tracks?
How can we use coffee and like.
So like for me,
I kind of mentioned this before,
when you're in,
when you're a coffee person,
when you're a barista,
you're interacting with people at like
this really delicate point in their day,
you know,
they don't know what's going on.
They're coming to your coffee bar.
They,
you're usually the first person they've
seen other than their wife or whatever
and uh,
and they're,
they're not sure what kind of day
they're having.
And then if you give them something
that's sort of like,
tastes really good,
it makes them feel good.
It's like a great thing and if you.
And if you do that for people a lot,
you know,
you feel like you're doing something
positive for the world.
So I always get really focused on these
things.
Sure.
I mean,
you certainly do,
you know what I mean?
I think that anytime you can inspire
someone to,
you know,
you can inspire someone with your
passion for something I'm in.
I'm constantly inspired by things that I
don't want to have anything to do with.
You know,
like there's people that inspire me.
Like I watched that movie,
jiro dreams of sushi.
I don't want to make sushi or you know,
I really don't want to eat a.
I certainly do.
I was thinking literally thinking about
flying to Japan.
Yeah,
and booking a reservation.
I was going to try to see if I really
should call David Lee roth who lives in
Japan and in Japan.
Fuck jay.
Does David Lee roth lives in Japan and
practice sword fighting all day.
David lee ross,
one of the greatest bad motherfuckers to
ever walk the face of the planet.
Guy walks around and overhauls gives
zero fucks.
He's in his sixties and still doing new
things and challenging himself.
He lives in fucking Japan in tokyo with
his dog.
He has an apartment that's fucking David
Lee roth man.
He's a David Lee roth and he's got an
apartment like a normal person with a
dog in tokyo.
He's.
He's incredible.
Well,
if you do that,
if you go to Japan to.
There he is.
He's such a cool guy.
We allowed him to wear sunglasses
indoors.
I didn't shit on him while we were
taking that photo.
That's an old school thing.
I thought those,
those old school rock stars,
they still wear sunglasses indoors and
we let them get away with it.
Um,
but if you do that,
if you go visit jiro,
let me know and I'll,
I'll send you some coffee places that
are sort of the equivalent of that.
Ah,
in Japan,
Japan.
Really.
So these coffee guys.
So in many ways Japan,
there's a concept in japanese called
coda and that is like practice,
practice,
practice until you're the best in the
world and keep practicing and keep
getting it wrong,
but you're going to get better all the
time.
You know,
and it's,
it's evident in martial arts,
it's evident in jiro dreams of sushi.
Right?
And so he's like,
focus
was what they were calling each other.
Was that the phrase?
This phrase?
Yeah.
And uh,
and this exists for coffee to this,
this idea of getting it perfect.
There's this one coffee Place I went to
last time.
I was in Japan that would blow your
mind.
It's this guy that's like super.
He has this coffee equipment.
I walked in,
my wife,
uh,
she actually found out about this place
from a japanese friend of hers.
We walk into this place and he's got all
this crazy equipment like,
like you'd like it.
It's like,
it's like weird weirdly excessive coffee
equipment.
I'm saying what is going on?
And also in this place,
this guy has stereo equipment,
these giant speakers playing,
uh,
playing like perfect the and the
incredible turntable and all this stuff
playing like perfect classical music and
he's serving.
His goal is to serve you the perfect
coffee while you're listening to the
perfect music and it's like a crazy
library and this guy takes five minutes
to make you a cup of coffee.
Whoa.
Um,
but along it,
well,
he's just like practice.
He's getting it right.
You know,
he's,
he's nailing it.
He'll throw stuff away if it's not
perfect.
And how will we know if it's perfect?
Well,
it's like judo man.
It's like he's just trying to get to the
ultimate coffee experience.
There's another guy named katsu.
He's got a place called bear pond
espresso and he learned about coffee in
New York and so he's trying to bring the
New York city coffee experience to,
to central tokyo,
you know,
and he's got this little place.
He,
he,
this guy,
he shows up to his shop like an hour and
a half before they open these spins,
that hour and a half,
making his coffee taste right and taste
it,
throw it away,
adjust.
Tasted again.
You know.
And if it's not right,
he doesn't open.
There is.
Yeah.
That's,
that's,
that's katsu man.
God damn.
That place is awesome.
And that's in tokyo.
That guy is a bad ass.
He sounds like a,
he is a coffee bad ass.
And him and
his wife,
that's all,
you know as a tiny little place you go
in there if it's not open it's because
he's trying to get the coffee right.
and uh,
you just wait and then you go in there
and he makes you awesome coffee.
Did you go there?
Oh yeah.
You fly there just to drink off?
No,
but I was there for it,
but I definitely made it make a trip.
Every time I'm in tokyo I go to visit
katsu.
He's the man,
so he rides around on a motorcycle and
I'd never seen that before.
Oh yeah.
That's his place.
It just jumped off a motorcycle.
Yeah.
He's a bad ass now.
Are they places like that here and you
find that on vimeo there's a whole,
like three minute documentary about.
Oh yeah.
Say the name of the documentary so folks
could watch it if they want to.
Uh,
I think it's just bare pond espresso.
Bear upon his press.
What other spots like that in los
angeles or they're really,
really exceptionally good coffee spots.
Yeah.
So the place I actually bought that for
you here locally in a,
in a shop in culver city called kronos,
anti c o g n o s c e n t I cognizant.
Yeah.
Cognitive study.
Which means those in the know.
There you go.
Yeah.
There's a queue.
That's a pool cue.
I play pool.
There's a pool cue called the cognizant
and by my friend joe gold.
He designed this show gold.
Well,
it's a very common name.
Yeah,
but he's a.
He lives in chicago.
Okay.
One of the best pool cue manufacturers
are artists I should say in the world.
Cool.
Yeah,
and the cognitive one.
and he had them designed based on.
He hired these engineers to figure out
what was the exact perfect taper and the
right combinations of woods,
like mostly uses ebony.
He used all kinds of different Woods,
but most of the time he uses ebony with
a maple shaft and certain woolman dried
aged wood because the wood has to be
dry.
They can camp any water in the water,
a little move as it dries and it
changes,
so they have to cut the wood down.
He starts out in a big block and you
slowly cut it down over long periods of
time until it becomes a doll.
He could make a qwiff because you have
to allow for the wood to move as it
dries.
Second guitar maker.
It's very,
very similar and there's.
There's a big difference amongst pool
players in woods and how they perform on
a table.
If they have a different,
like a maple,
a forearm of the queue.
There's a joint in most cues and then
the shaft is almost always maple.
The maple forum will be very Different
than a coco bolo for like a springiness.
Yes,
yes.
There's maple is a little bit more
gentle and forgiving and a cocoa elbows
a little more dense than ebony is
denser.
Still having also is heavier so it has
like a more forward balance to it.
The middle of the queue will hold a lot
of weight,
so sometimes people who prefer a maple
queue,
we'll go with the steel joint.
So the steel in the middle sort of
access like a pendulum because the
weight is forward on the queue.
Like the balance of the cubes is very
important,
but it's also an artist in thing.
It's like it's just like this coffee
thing and a lot of ways is the people
that are really into it are really into
it and they,
you know,
the guys who make pool cues,
like there's they're artists and they're
doing a lot of,
especially guys like joe gold do it on a
very high end level.
They're making a functional piece of
art.
It's very beautiful to look at as well.
Yeah.
This is joe's work here.
These are like really super fancy ones.
Were you seeing the end lazy bottom and
these.
I dOn't know whether he's going to have
a wrap on.
These are what sometimes they make some
with no rap,
meaning they'll know leather around the
handle and some people prefer leather
around the handle.
There's a whole art to that too,
I think.
Yeah,
I'm unbelievably fascinated by that as
well,
but like I said,
I'm in anything like a guitar makers.
I don't play guitar,
but I watched a documentary on how a guy
makes a guitar.
I think I watched a whole documentary on
a mongolian bowmaker last night because
making traditional mongolian like
recurve bows,
you guys doing it at all these different
woods and using animal horns and seeing
you and It will glue that they make from
from fish.
I'd so much rather
pay my money for something that is like
handmade.
Yeah.
It means that their soul into it.
Yeah,
it does.
It means something.
It turns in our normal artifact into
something really special.
Yeah.
It's functional and you also get a
feeling from using that thing.
You know,
whether it is a handmade knife that
you're chopping up food within your
kitchen.
You know that somewhere in brooklyn,
the guy you know works in a shop that
cuts that metal and polishes it down and
sharpens it up and then sends it to you
and you're,
you're receiving a labor of love.
You know,
you're.
Yeah.
You're,
you're receiving the fruits of someone's
creativity.
There's something about,
yeah,
handmade,
stuff like that.
Well,
something about us human beings that we
really appreciate other people's effort
work.
That's why you want to have someone's
artwork on your wall.
You know,
what's,
why you want to,
a piece of furniture that someone made.
It's like there's something uniquely
satisfying instead of like something at
ikea that's just like some form block
thing that's made in a factory and it's
totally true and spit out.
But if you could buy a couch that Some
guy actually carve the wood and,
and,
and planted the or put the cushions in
place and you know,
embroidered it all and oh my god,
that'd be amazing.
You get excited about it when you sit in
it and you're sitting in someone's work.
Totally.
So anyway,
you guys places
one,
the chi is,
he's the guy who was an architect but
got turned on to cough
and this is in culver city is the city.
Yeah.
So cognizant,
any coffee,
there you go,
there you go.
And then another great place and yeah,
in la that I like a lot,
um,
is it's called g and b coffee.
these guys,
uh,
charles babinski and kyle glanville got
together.
Then they're the gnb and uh,
and they put together a coffee program.
Amazing downtown la.
Their shop is.
And uh,
um,
charles is the current reigning.
Okay.
Do you know we have champions like
barista champion?
We've met a contest of champions.
Yeah.
What do they do?
Like crossfit?
no,
we,
it's like a coffee.
Anybody ever breached
until they died because that.
Has anybody ever breached it to like
John Henry just like dropped from.
Yeah.
Well like,
you know,
they have contests to see if people can
do things for $20 a day.
I like an endurance thing.
Yeah.
Have they ever have a barista till you
drop it?
I know.
No,
they shouldn't do that now because
people will wind up dying.
They would die.
People are crazy.
We need to limit the amount of
competition that people were actually
allowed to involve.
And that's true.
So this is the coffee,
the coffee competItions that we do and
there are,
it's a,
there's a barista thing where they're
making espresso.
There's a brewer's thing where there
brewing coffee,
there's a tasters thing where they,
they're,
they're competing on how well they can
taste coffee and discern the differences
between coffee and stuff.
So there is a coffee version of the
Somalia?
Yeah,
absolutely.
So you drank this,
you would know this is from Ethiopia if,
if you didn't,
if you didn't drink this,
if you drank this and you called
yourself a coffee pro and you weren't
able to identify it as,
as a chef,
you,
that would be a major.
Um,
you'd be a faker.
Well,
kind of.
Yeah.
I mean this is one of the classic
origins of coffee that you need to be
able to identify what could you get
confused by?
Like if you were really worried,
like if you had a bet your mortgage on
whether or not you could nail one,
which would be,
what would be a tricky one?
The differences between what coffee's
still in central America.
They get really new because I mean think
about that central american isthmus
there,
you know,
El Salvador,
Guatemala,
Costa Rica,
Nicaragua,
there all right next to each other and
as you said,
like the same.
Very similar,
right?
So those coffees tastes very similar but
like a coffee from another great coffee
growing area is right in the middle of
Kenya and Kenya is right just south of
Ethiopia.
But the coffee taste completely
different,
huh?
Um,
and uh,
so there's a city called the okay.
JusT as yoga chef is special in,
in,
in Ethiopia,
a place called neery and y e r I n Kenya
is really special and that it,
it the coffee,
their tastes like a black berries,
you know,
like this is like lemons there.
It tastes like black berries or black
currents.
Really beautiful and savory like meat.
now what would happen if you took that
stuff though?
like you took some plants from that area
and then moved them to Hawaii?
That's a great question.
You usually get into the coffee
business.
You're asking the right questions in
general.
We don't have very many examples of
that.
Um,
because only recently have people
started to move coffee around.
But,
but I tasted once a coffee from a farm
in El Salvador that had the kenyan
coffees from this,
uh,
this place in neary planted on it.
And I,
at the time I didn't know anything but I
was tasting this coffee and I accused
the guy that was working in my lab with
me of making a mistake.
It tastes like kenyan coffee,
huh?
So,
uh,
it's the varieties that have grown to
these places that are in many ways
determine these flavors.
there's also a farm in,
in,
uh,
in Panama that was kind of accidentally
planted with some coffees from Ethiopia
and the coffee tastes like ethiopian
coffee.
Really?
Yeah.
So is there a similarity in the climate?
Yeah,
if the climate is the same and they've.
Coffee variety is the same because
remember,
all these thousands of varieties that
exist in the world,
you know,
if in,
in,
in yoga chef,
they grow three different varieties
there.
If you go to yoga chef and ask a farmer
what varieties of coffee he's growing,
he's got a choice of three m and they're
different from anywhere else in the
world.
Those they look different.
You can see that they're different,
right?
Like those little tiny ones that we
have.
Exactly the,
it's called [inaudible].
A mocha.
Yeah.
Mocha is the variety.
So mlk,
k a.
This came from Yemen somehow and made it
to Hawaii and they planned it.
That's rusty's hawaiian by the way.
And it's really delicious and really
tiny.
They're like little,
they're like seeds,
almost like bbs.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a good way to describe it.
On pbs.
Yeah.
Um,
so how often do you travel around the
world helping people define the flavors
of their coffees?
Well now I have a kid so I don't do it
as much anymore,
but there was a,
there was a decade there where I would
travel a one year,
200 days in a year.
Well,
it waS,
I was,
uh,
I was just bugged out of your mind doing
coffee.
Yeah.
Tasting it more than a lot of times,
by the way,
when we're tasting coffee will spit it
out so you don't get too fucked up.
They just taste it and spit it.
That's interesting.
Do you feel bad about spitting it out?
Sometimes?
Sometimes you don't.
If you don't,
if stute delicious and you don't want
to,
you can just drink,
drink it.
Yeah.
Wow.
But,
um,
but yeah,
but there's a lot of.
I mean it's not just me.
There's lots of,
there's lots of people out there right
now.
In fact,
I was chatting with a guy and in Kenya
this morning,
now what can be done
about the soil itself is their
composting then improves the health of
the plant.
Question that.
Yeah,
that one of the issues with coffee is
you take all this coffee out from a farm
and wherever,
Kenya and you bring the coffee here,
but you got to,
you got to be bringing stuff back to the
soil all the time.
And otherwise the soil will be depleted.
So getting nutrients back in the soil is
really important.
Composting is a big deal.
It's good to have,
um,
access to manure if you can from cattle
or chickens or whatever that they put
it.
It's a lot
preferred type of manure that you use.
It depends on the soil because I know
people are really in a chicken shit.
Chicken shit is great because we have
chickens and people asking us for our
shit.
Yeah.
Well it's like,
it's like dynamite.
That stuff.
It's weird.
People ask me for shit.
Um,
so what about like rotten vegetables?
Most any
good coffee farm will have a gigantic
compost heap that they,
that they have the coffee pulp and like
that from when they process the coffee
plus manure,
chicken manure,
all sorts of stuff
and this is all sort of leave and,
and like piled up and then it's evenly
distributed over the farm
and then they have to carry it.
So farmers,
we'll put it in a bag on their back and
walk up these mountains and like put,
you know,
two or three kilograms of manure on each
coffee plant.
Now one coffee plant will produce about
a pound of coffee in a year.
So this gives you an idea how much work
it is.
That's insane.
It's crazy.
one coffee plant produces a full bag of
coffee in one year.
In a year.
Yeah.
So why isn't coffee a million dollars?
that's a great question.
What would happen if coffee can be grown
in the United States?
It is probably would cost a million
dollars.
What?
YoU know,
that's why you know,
straight.
This was probably pretty expensive.
This straight hawaiian coffee.
Oh yeah.
It was not cheap at all.
It's very expensive.
I think it's like,
well,
I forget,
I shouldn't say
yeah,
but anyway,
it's a lot of money and that's why it's
because it's because it's incredibly
laboR intensive.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Now I'm,
the issue that they're having with a lot
of farms is the depletion of the soil,
correct.
Minerally deficient soils had been,
that's been an issue with farmers since
the 19 twenties when they first started
realizing.
Yeah.
And,
and then so,
um,
and this is a big challenge for all
agriculture but,
but coffee is no different how to
maintain fertility in your soil without,
because it takes a lot of work,
like a lot of labor to get stuff back.
And then,
um,
so chemical fertilizers,
another option for,
for farmers they use.
But that's a problem too because It
takes energy to make,
you know,
they burn gas basically to make npk
fertilizer,
which is chemical fertilizer.
So organic farms don't use that kind of
fertilizer.
They make their own with compost,
but it's so much effort.
It's just a huge lead,
expensive undertaking to do.
so it's a challenge.
It's one of the things that we face and
we talk about a lot in coffee.
Is there a variation in the flavor of a
plant that's been fertilized with the
chemical feRtilizer or synthetic or
whatever you call it as versed as
opposed to compost?
No,
as long as the.
As long as the plant is healthy,
it's possible to make it healthy in both
those ways.
So if the plant's healthy,
it's gonna make good coffee,
but it seems like a huge difference in
the chemical process itself.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean you obviously have to burn things
in order to.
It's like it's.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and then there are,
there's a lot of middle ground too.
I mean,
I would say most,
most good farmers or many good farmers
use a little bit of,
of synthetic fertilizer and a little bit
of compost as well,
and they kind of
multivitamins with a good diet.
That's exactly what it's like using
chemical fertilizer is the same as using
vitamin supplements.
You ever heard of a guy named dr joel
wallach?
No.
He's a doctor who wrote a book called
dead doctors don't lie and saw about
minerally sufficient,
insufficient soils and about a real
epidemic we have with minerally
deficient diets.
Now.
I don't know how much of what he said.
It's fuckery.
I need to really probably talk to
someone.
I'll talk to dr rhonda,
patrick about it.
Choose one of the guests that we have on
the podcast.
I'll say an actual scientist and yeah,
she really understands what she's
talking about,
but this guy was talking about areas in
the world where people live to be much
longer or live to me much older and
we're healthier and had darker hair
longer and that it was because they were
getting something called glacial milk,
which is the runoff like water from
glaciers.
They actually had like a milky quality
to it because it was so minerally rich
right now as their areas like that where
they grow coffee,
which minerally rich coffee people
like the legend.
There's a lot of legends and coffee.
Well,
yeah,
I mean about special areas that make
special coffee.
You know,
and you.
You mentioned earlier volcanic soils,
places that have volcanic soil that the
farmers,
if their coffee is great,
they will attribute it to all of these
things.
But so far there's not a lot of like
actual evidence to support any of that.
Um,
uh,
all it is is we know and we're
discovering these things all the time.
You know,
it's like what is the magic?
I'm sort of mixture of the right
variety,
the right climate,
the right kind of soil composition,
the right kind of husbandry.
It's this,
it's so many factors together.
It's,
I don't think it makes sense to isolate
one thing.
Another thing that people always ask me
is like if they're growing pine trees on
the farm with their green coffee,
can you tease the pine trees in the,
in the,
uh,
in the coffee itself.
And I'm pretty sure that there's no,
there's no way that,
that,
I mean,
I've never experienced that,
you know,
but people,
there's,
these legends kind of come up are around
cost and you do,
you do taste amazing things in coffee
that are inexplicably,
like that coffee that we just drank.
The definitely smells like lemons,
right?
Well,
it smells like a tea.
Yeah.
Like lemon tea.
Right.
And it tastes good even when it cools.
Oh yeah,
taste better.
I noticed that too.
It's just,
it's,
I don't know why is,
that's not the case with a lot of
coffee.
No,
no,
that's right.
Why is that?
What's.
Well coffee is,
we'll continue to extract over time.
So whIle it's been sitting in this,
in this thing,
it's continuing to extract.
It's going from,
maybe it was maybe 18 percent when I
pledged it in terms of percentage of
extraction and it keeps on going up as
it sits and so it'll evolve in terms of
flavor.
The other thing that changes is you.
So,
uh,
so there's this thing called habituation
in tasting things.
And uh,
I wasn't completely hip to this until I
taste scientist.
Um,
he,
he did this demonstration for me and he
did it with wine.
He said he,
he gave me a glass of this,
this,
a white wine from a New Zealand and he
had me taste it and he said,
you,
you taste that green bell pepper note in
this.
You know,
and that's the thing that they say about
wines from this area and I said,
yeah,
I can taste it,
and he says okay,
and then he gave me a little bit of
actual green bell pepper and he said,
eat that,
and I did.
And then he said,
Okay,
now taste the wine again,
and I tasted the wine again and it
tastes Like a completely different wine.
And I said,
what happened?
He said,
okay,
so that,
that wine had this chemical in it and he
named the chemical.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was the green bell pepper
chemical and then he's.
And then when he gave me the green bell
pepper,
it overwhelmed my senses with that same
smell.
And so you know how if you're,
if,
if you use windex in your house,
you smell it for a while and you're
overwhelmed by it and then in a few
minutes you can't smell it anymore.
It's not that it's gone away,
it's just that your brain has sort of
screened it out.
Well,
all factory senses dePend on change.
Exactly.
And so once you get used to something,
you can't smell it anymore.
Yes.
And so it.
Same thinG happens with coffee.
If you're drinking coffee and there's an
overwhelming element than your,
your olfactory,
we'll screen it out and then you start
tasting different things.
So tHings change over time.
So smell certainly does enhance tastes
or change tastes.
Yeah.
In,
in coffee especially,
it's,
it's at least half of thing.
It doesn't whine as well.
Like I find that like,
you know,
a good wine like are like red wine.
When I smell a good red wIne,
like the smell of it actually makes it
seem somewhat more delicious.
Yeah.
Will flavor the definition of flavor is
the,
is the combination of aromatic and taste
together.
So if you eliminate it,
if you have a cold or something and you
eliminate your aromatics,
suddenly food doesn't taste right.
Nothing is right because you're only
tasting sweet,
sour,
salty,
bitter,
and savory,
which is what you can experience on your
tongue.
But your nose is able to get thousands
of things.
So there's this,
there's this phenomenon that happens
when you're tasting things.
Um,
and uh,
it's,
it,
it's called retro nasal,
so when you swallow this is weird,
but you swallow something and then it
coats your throat and that the aromatics
kind of go backwards up through your
nose from your throat.
Whoa.
And um,
and it's,
that's called retro nasal from the back
of your notes and so you're actually
smelling things at the same time that
you're swallowing them.
That is fascinating.
Is there any restaurant in the los
angeles area that gets the whole thing
right?
Like great food,
great wine and great coffee.
That's a great question.
Why doesn't someone nailed that?
Somebody should.
Somebody should have like coffee,
like this.
Yeah,
like the Perfect cup of coffee roasted
March 4th,
you know,
so roasted a week ago.
What's today's date?
What's the offIcial day right now?
It's the 17th.
What is it?
10th,
10th the 10th.
So six,
six,
17.
I don't know what day it is.
Yeah.
How about that?
Seven days off.
Yeah,
I knew it was one of those mondays.
Um,
so six days ago.
It's really recently roasted.
That Would be an amazing thing for
someone to pull off in a restaurant,
have like really delicious wines to go
with really delicious food and have the
same effort put into the coffee's.
A few restaurants are starting to really
work on it and drill it right.
Yeah.
And what do they know that I know of in
la,
but none.
But how dare you?
La?
Yeah.
I'm sure there might be.
I just haven't been there yet.
San francisco must,
uh,
san francisco has a couple.
There was one in baltimore of all places
really?
That did an amazing job.
Is it still open woodberry kitchen yet?
It's still a great coffee service.
Amazing coffee,
sir.
Amazing conference service and amazing
food is amazing.
I mean,
the guy,
this guy named spike does this.
I mean,
he is amazing.
This dude.
Well,
I'm going to get that number from you
because I'm going there in a couple of
weeks in baltimore.
Oh,
you have to eat it with kitchen.
It's great.
I'm gone.
Yeah.
Done.
How about that?
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
awesome.
what,
what else can we talk about when it
comes to coffee?
Is there anything that we missed?
No,
I mean,
uh,
no.
I don't knoW.
I mean the,
the,
uh,
some of the things that,
that,
uh,
people always want to know is about
decaf.
Yes.
That was another thing.
I,
yeah.
I'm glad you brought that up.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean it's the thing you see when you
work in coffee,
you go to cocktail parties or something.
People always ask you these questions.
They ask you what's your favorite coffee
and why?
Because they want to know.
They also want to know what the deal
with decaf is,
is what is the deal?
Well,
I mean,
so coffee has this alkaloid a caffeine
and um,
and then you have to get it out.
So the first way that they got it out as
they use it,
a solvent like,
uh,
like paint thinner.
Yeah.
Kind of more like dry cleaning solvent.
This is god.
This is a,
a 100 Years ago.
And they noticed that it was able to
take the caffeine out and that was the
original.
But nobody who wants to use that in
there.
So over the years they've developed
better ways of doing it using carbon
dioxide or charcoal filters to get the,
to get the caffeine out.
And how much do you actually get out?
Because I had heard that starbucks has a
particularly high caffeine content of
their regular coffee and that there
might be a little bit left to that when
you have decaf sound right to me.
No,
no,
I,
I don't see any reason why starbucks
would have a higher caffeine content
of their coffee.
So it's just an urban legend.
Sounds like engine to me.
Yeah.
Um,
what about the decaf,
does it have any caffeine in it at all
or is it trace amounts?
Trace trace
and,
and uh,
uh,
so,
you know,
people that are like allergic sensitive
to it shouldn't drink decaffeinated
coffee,
but,
but people that are uh,
uh,
but you know,
most and each of these methods is
slightly different,
but trace amounts of caffeine and
decaffeinated coffee,
that's good.
The good methods,
the swiss water process,
for example,
you may have heard of,
um,
is,
uh,
is one,
there's a number of these methods that
are really good at getting,
getting the caffeine out and not
destroying the flavor of the coffee.
So what is the law says?
Starbucks tall decaf.
A tall,
which is a small.
Has nine point five milligrams of
caffeine in it.
Okay.
What is a normal cup of coffee habit?
Like a hundred 50,
200 years.
So that's the tray.
So it's a little bit,
a little bit,
but it's not caffeine free.
It's just low caffeine.
Yeah.
but that's pretty low.
I mean,
you know.
Sure.
But unless you're super sensitive to it.
But if you have a 20 ounce decaf you're
getting.
What about 18?
Maybe sort of double.
What does that.
A 16 ounce.
Sixteen ounces double,
right?
Because that's an eight is a tall and
eight.
Now,
I don't know.
This is the starbucks bar language that
don't write well.
They're get all goofy with grande's.
Call him.
I know venti is 20 ounces.
I know.
Yeah.
That's silly.
Called medium.
Just don't call it tall either.
That shit ain't tall.
And what world?
Gulliver travels.
What world is that tall?
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
So if someone is a really sensitive to
caffeine though,
they can also still probably get a
little bit of a caffeine kick.
Yeah,
that's true.
if there's a decaf,
they're super sensitive to it.
So it's not caffeine free.
It's not.
Yeah.
I guess called decaf but it's not
decaffeinated.
It's only.
Mostly.
It's mostly decaf.
Decaffeinated.
Yeah.
Um,
but the flavor,
right?
Well,
so now the flavors.
Okay,
great.
I've,
I've done this,
I've tasted great decaffeinate a great
coffee that becomes decaffeinated and
it's certainly the flavor is impacted by
caffeine,
by the removal of caffeine,
by the process that goes through,
but it's still delicious coffee.
Okay.
Like give us an example of a delicious
decaffeinated coffee that we should.
Well,
any of these,
any qa,
any coffee company that's like putting
extraordinary care into their regular
coffee,
it's very likely that they will be
putting extraordinary care into their
decaf to.
And it Just,
you should ask them about it,
you know,
I mean,
uh,
you know,
if you engage with them and they weRe
proud of their decaf and his chances are
that they are putting a lot of care into
it.
And I know that,
okay,
I used to run a coffee company,
coffee program for a coffee company back
east called counterculture coffee and I
put extra effort into my decaffeinated
coffee because I knew that the people
that were drinking that we're drinking
it only for the flavor.
They weren't drinking it for the drug
effect.
They,
they just,
they cared enough about coffee that they
wanted to drink it just because of the
way that it tasted.
And I felt like that was a
responsibility,
you know,
that's a very interesting point because
you're not dealing with any people just
looking for a drug.
Right.
And,
and so and so,
uh,
but the,
I mean,
the problem,
the problem with decaf I think is that
consumers who drink decaffeinated
coffee,
they don't necessarily expect to pay
more.
They feel lIke it should be the same,
you know,
and I get that,
but it does cost money to put it through
the process of decaf
and eating well,
don't they feel like that most coffees
overpriced in the first place?
I don't think people really truly
realize the amount of effort when you
broke it down by one pound is one tree
for a fucking year.
It's totally true.
What is the,
is that an eight ounce bag of coffee?
What does that.
How many?
What was that?
This is bringing that real hawaiian
roasters.
Was that sales is probably 16 ounces.
Fourteen ounces,
14 ounces.
So it's essentially a year of one plant.
Yeah,
that's an unbelievable man.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy.
And you can get definitely 20 bucks or
whatever the hell it is.
So we have this idea
deal of the in the depression and nickel
cup of coffee and,
and uh,
you know,
that's what my grandparents had access
to a nickel cup of coffee
or a cup of coffee.
They think it's stupid.
Meanwhile,
grow your own coffee dummy.
Good luck.
But I mean that was intentional.
I mean,
restaurants at that time,
that was,
they were losing money on their five
cent,
cup of coffee's even in the twenties
really because,
but they did that.
It was sort of a lost leader.
They were trying to get people into the
restaurants,
you know,
so,
um,
but it kind of stuck in people's mind
that coffee should be cheap and,
and,
and it shouldn't be.
It's,
it,
it in my view,
coffee should be the best you can
possibly make it taste.
And then if that costs money,
whatever,
just drink.
Bless.
So let me ask you this.
Save your traveling across America and
you stop at a diner because you're
hungry.
And do you even fuck around even order a
cup of coffee?
Sometimes I do.
Sometimes I get sad when they bring you
out.
That little stupid white cop.
It is tasted.
I mean,
I love diners.
you know,
I love to eat at diners.
I freaking love,
but you don't love that.
Drink coffee there.
And I love pancakes and hash browns and
all that stuff.
And uh,
I wish that the few times I've gone to
places where the coffee was out
regionally.
Good.
And did they tell you it was really
good?
Cool.
Yeah.
Sometimes sometimes they're,
they're proud of their,
their deal and they all make it good.
So it's someone who takes as much effort
into their omelets,
right as they do into their craft.
Well,
it should be,
yeah,
it should be expected if it's
financially feasible,
but that's.
And That's what it comes down to.
People got to be willing to pay for good
stuff.
Like what does the bag like this
delicious bag of ethiopian.
You're A good show.
Good show.
Usually there'll be,
I don't know,
maybe 12 or $13.
Dude,
I'm going to sleep with this shit next
to my pillow.
It's good.
I just want this.
I hope you drink it,
drink the shit out of this sometimes.
And this always happened to me when I,
you know,
I'd get a special coffee,
I give it to my parents and they'd throw
it in the freezer and save it for a
special occasion because they're like,
well,
none of this special coffee,
you know.
No,
no,
we're drinking this all day.
I'm going to put that out in the kitchen
too.
I'm not going to put in the freezer.
I don't have to register.
I drink,
drink,
drink it quickly.
All right,
so we're going to leave this out and
we're going to report on this and thank
you for coming by and thank you to
wrecking ball coffee for making this
awesome ethiopian years.
It was a pleasure talking to you.
Um,
is there anything else we can cover?
Anything that people a don't know about
coffee that should know anything else
while we're gearing up somebody that was
looking at the twitter feed and somebody
mentioned something.
Oh,
okay.
I've got a few things that you're,
that people might be interested.
You ready to
catch it?
Coffee.
Oh,
I've had that kopi luwak.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but that's made by a civet they eat,
right?
Yeah,
I've had it.
I've ordered it.
Interesting.
Folks who don't know really is shit out
by this cat thing.
Right.
It's like it's in the cat family that.
Well,
yeah,
I think it's more like a raccoon.
Yeah.
And then eats the beans and then ships
them out and then they take it out of
its poop and when it goes through its
digestive tract,
it imparts a very mellow taste to the
coffee.
So it got in this movie,
you know the bucket list,
everybody.
What movies?
The bucket.
There's a movie called the bucket list.
Jack nicholson.
And you don't remember this,
but.
No,
I never heard of it.
It's about some old guys and they had a
bucket list of things to have things to
do before they died.
And one of the things was they drink the
coffee and so that of course it started
a rash of people asking people like me
about this,
this,
this.
Here's the animal.
Look at that cute little thing.
Well,
that's fake,
man.
He's not really talking.
Oh,
that's the beans that he pooped out.
I first tried that with my friend tate,
who's one of the owners of caveman
coffee.
Tate's always been a,
a,
a crazy coffee kind of sore.
But we were in miami and we saw this
caveman coffee by the way.
Uh,
he's out of New Mexico.
Okay,
cool.
I'm in this place in miami was some sort
of a specialty coffee joint.
There was a restaurant that had these
really expensive coffees and I forget
what it was like 30 bucks a glass a cup
or somethIng really expensive.
Something really nutty because it came
out of this cats.
But yeah,
and the problem is that it's really rare
and that's why it's expensive.
It's good though.
I've had it.
It's delicious.
I'm glad.
Yeah,
I'm glad you.
Okay.
There can be a.
There can be some pretty rotten of this.
wait a minute.
It comes out of cats assets rotten.
how weird
it is.
There are these places where they have
the cats in cages in it a fuck.
You know what I mean?
And we think of that.
You got me now.
God damn it.
I'm sorry.
I'm not trying to.
Yeah,
you're black fish.
My kopi luwak was black fleece.
Black fish is that new documentary
that's killing seaworld,
right?
Because people got a chance to see what
it's really.
Right.
Fucking seaworld Is terrible.
It's terrible there.
Their slave colonies,
they're enslaving intelligent beings
that we can understand.
It's true.
It is.
It is 100 percent and,
and uh,
yeah,
so I,
I got a touch of that same sadness when
I saw that,
when I saw that and I've been to the
places where they do this,
imagining it just stands to reason.
if you have a product like this that's
very expensive,
then you're going to have these fucking
animals.
do you get a lot of fraud because it's
so expensive,
you know,
I would imagine so.
And,
and,
but,
you know,
I mean the amount of pleasure that you
can get from a coffee,
like the one I brought you or some of
these other ones that you've mentioned.
Um,
you know,
it's not solely necessarily to go to
that extent.
The other thing I noticed on the twitter
feed,
somebody mentioned coffee going extinct.
There was a news,
uh,
about a year ago,
there was a news thIng that was talking
about coffee going extinct.
Um,
and,
and uh,
and it's because,
so that this is tied into this,
uh,
this Ethiopia thing.
Um,
the fact that,
you know,
98,
99 percent of the total genetic
diversity of coffee is in Ethiopia.
And not only in in the country,
but in one.
There you go,
you're,
you're fast on the um,
it's not even Ethiopia,
all,
it's the south west part of Ethiopia
where coffee is indigenous to
pull an image of the beans itself like
that,
like that.
Like you gotta get a blow up on one of
those because most people don't even
know what coffee beans look like.
So those are,
we call them coffee cherries for obvious
reasons.
Yeah,
I mean they look like a fruit.
It's so interesting because we think of
coffee as,
you know,
if you,
if you're crazy,
you grind your own stuff,
right?
That's how most people think.
But it's already cooked and roasted and
yeah,
we think of it as food
in coffee,
you know,
and you know,
uh,
one of the biggest things that we can do
for people that is,
yeah,
it's beautiful grapes.
Get people to understand that coffee is
the seed of a fruit.
I need to get some of that coffee.
Fruit I want to eat,
but you'd have to send me the dry stuff.
Where can I go and actually buy the
fruit and eat it?
Is there a place compete in san diego,
santa barbara,
California.
So that's right.
That's right.
Five minutes away from here or
something.
Yeah.
I fucking love santa barbara.
I've actually thought about moving
there.
Oh,
I'm there.
So what am I there?
I think I'm there in april or something
should go visit.
jay's a great guy.
You go.
The fruit is delicious.
You eat fruit,
right?
I love fruit.
Yeah.
Then this is the.
This is the guy I'm there in santa
barbara.
May second.
Friday,
May 2nd.
I'm at the lobero theater with joey
diaz.
Yeah.
go check.
So I will do.
I will definitely go and check that out
because I want to go just to support
that guy.
I love when someone does something that
cool,
you know,
it takes a crazy project like that and
then seven years.
He's a cool guy for sure.
Well listen man,
this is really fascinating stuff.
I'm really interested in,
uh,
I really,
appreciate you coming on here and
educating us and giving us all the uh,
the low down on coffee.
I've been,
um,
been on a journey to kind of understand
and learn the process of this over the
last few months,
just really kind of digging deep into
the coffee flavor a barrel.
It's,
it's really been fascinating stuff and
very intriguing and stimulating in a,
in a lot of ways.
just the ideas behind it.
Like it's cool to uncover this whole
sort of community of people trying to
enhance flavors and tight taste them and
change.
I mean,
I had no idea there was a specialty
coffee association of America until just
a few days ago.
Yeah,
well,
I mean serious business and you want to
see a.org.
You want to hear a crazy thing you're
talking about like intellectual
connection and stuff like that.
Um,
so coffee was invented in Ethiopia as we
said in,
in Ethiopia.
They do it like a coffee ceremony,
like a,
you know,
it's a very ceremonial way to prepare it
and drink it.
And when they do the coffee ceremony,
they,
It's like they gather people together
from the village,
they and they talk about things.
They talk about the news of the village,
they talk about things that are going on
in the world.
When coffee moved from Ethiopia to
Yemen,
totally different deal.
Like in Ethiopia,
it's always a woman that makes coffee,
whereas in Yemen it wasn't like that,
but they still would talk about news and
intellectual and stuff like that.
Then coffee moved from Yemen to europe,
um,
you know,
Italy and england and places like that
and the coffee house still remained a
place for intellectual exchange and
discourse and stuff like that.
They planned the american revolution in
coffee houses,
you know,
in
we're wired,
right?
They're like,
fuck,
there's something about,
there's something about coffee that like
that,
like gets your mind going as well as
stimulates you and wakes you up.
But also the tea party movement like
that,
that had an effect on the way the United
States took off just by simply the fact
that they went from tea to coffee.
That's what the,
the,
there is.
There are people who speculate that
that's totally valid.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that coffee consumption is a part of the
american,
uh,
drive to ingenuity and imagination.
Ron's fucking speed.
We're country on speed.
I wonder if they could show gross
domestic product posts.
Starbucks.
Not starbucks impacted people's
productivity,
but still right.
If you go to
somebody at a coffee shop,
you're going to talk about something
that's different than going to drink
with somebody at a bar or have dinner
with somebody or something like that.
It's different.
It's somehow more about exchanging info
nation,
more imagination.
It's stimulating.
The stimulant of caffeine in coffee is
stimulating and then the flavor is
enriching.
You enjoy the flavor and then you get
fucking happy and it's been that way
since the origin of coffee.
Coffee houses.
Yeah.
Coffeehouses were always thought of as
places where people read poetry and you
know.
Yeah.
And he politics,
etc. And as you said,
plan revolutions.
That's interesting to me.
Yeah,
it is interesting and that's one of the
reasons
that I think that I like to work in
coffee because I'm into that sort of
thing.
Anyway.
Intellectual engagement,
creativity,
you know,
music,
poetry,
politics,
these,
this,
this is always been like that.
It's like this.
And in asia,
in arabia,
everywhere the coffee goes to second.
Do you feel like coffee doesn't get
enough credit for the impact that it has
had culturally?
Yeah,
I think
I,
I do think sometimes it bums me out this
idea of like cheap people want cheap,
abundant coffee,
but it's just,
it's only function is as a drug to get
them to work in the morning,
you know,
and it's been cheapened by our culture.
Um,
but,
but It's it special and,
and it could go away,
you know,
really well.
Yeah.
So that,
this whole extinction thing is about,
about how we're 98 percent of this,
this,
the origin of coffee is because of
climate change.
The scientist who does this work is done
the projections and if and if the
weather there as predicted increases by
a few degrees,
then the coffee won't be able to survive
and it could be 80 percent wiped out in
these natural coffee forests in 50
years.
Whoa.
And then then we'll be up a creek
because the motherload of genetic origin
of coffee will be gone essentially.
That's intense.
And then can there be steps done too,
guard that we're trying to do that in
the industry.
So we had actually at a conference about
a year ago on this very question where
we talked about preservation of the
genetic diversity of coffee,
which means taking coffee out of
Ethiopia,
planting it elsewhere to make sure that
we've got other examples of the same,
of the genetic diversity,
diversity in other parts of the world.
um,
you know,
preserving it.
There's other ways to preserve a coffee,
you know,
by freezing the seeds,
and putting them in storage.
So if we need them,
we can go back to them.
This has been an eyeopening podcast,
man.
I learned more about coffee today than I
had in 46 years of life on this planet.
Thank you peter.
I really,
really appreciate you taking your time
and educating us and I really appreciate
your passion.
And the website is [inaudible] dot org
that has a specialty coffee association
of America.
And follow peter on twitter.
It's peter giuliano g I u l a n o l I n
e l l I a n.
Okay.
She,
I,
u l I a and o giuliano peter,
peter giuliano g I,
peter first p e t e r g I u
g a u l I a n.
Oh that's a lot of work but thank you
joe.
And it's so easy.
Joe rogan,
talese giuliano.
But it has a lot more flow to it.
And again see a.org.
Thank you very much.
Really,
really appreciate it.
And thanks also to our sponsors.
Thanks to um,
tends to naturebox naturebox.
Go to naturebox.com and use the.
Hold on.
I'm sorry I lost my place.
Naturebox fuckers.
You're awesome.
Delicious.
Shit.
You confuse the shit out of me.
It's code name.
Rogan,
I believe.
Oh,
we don't
need to believe we need to know.
So give me a second here.
A naturebox.
Yeah,
here we go.
Yes it is naturebox.com/rogan.
It's not a code word.
So naturebox.com/rogan.
That's why we looked it up.
Otherwise we confused the fuck out of
people.
So good at naturebox.
Dot com slash rogan.
Try naturebox and get 50 slash 50
percent off your first box.
That's naturebox.com.
Slash rogan,
very delicious stuff and as I said
before,
a lot of variables and as far as like
what you can order,
you can go super healthy and go medium
healthy.
You can go pretzels,
but a really good,
yummy,
delicious sit shit with a lot of
positives on it.
No artificial sweeteners,
no artificial flavors,
no artificial colors,
no partially hydrogenated oils and like
I said,
the blueberry almonds or the bomb
diggity son.
Go get yourself some of that and we're
also brought to you by legal zoom.com.
Legalzoom.com is a an excellent sponsor
as well and one that we really enjoy
here on the podcast because we get a lot
of positive feedback.
In fact,
nine out of 10 people who've used legal
zoom said they would use it again.
Go to legalzoom.com and use the code
word rogan in the referral box at
checkout for more savings.
Thanks also to [inaudible] dot com.
Go to o,
n n I t use the code name,
rogan and save 10 percent off any and
all supplements.
Now bitches.
You know as much about coffee as you
ever need to,
unless you become a freak like peter
giuliano.
Alright we will see you guys tomorrow
with a try.
Cast Dr. Christopher Ryan and duncan
trussell return and we're doing our
threesome thing that we always do a once
a month.
So much love.
See you guys soon and tomorrow night ice
house almost sold out.
Get on it.